feces and had been speared on the wall
saying i felt bad i felt degraded
these dedicated workers were here too
when the capital was attacked
as where many committed journalists who
report on our work to the american
people
to make this place safe going forward we
must answer some key questions
first and foremost on many of our minds
is what took so long
to deploy the national guard that day
both because of decisions made in the
capitol complex but also by
others in the federal government we must
find out what was known about the
potential for violence before the attack
and how that intelligence was shared
with law enforcement partners
including the officials responsible for
protecting the capital
there are also important questions to be
asked about how information
concerning those threats was
communicated to rank and file officers
and it's vital that we explore necessary
reforms to the structure of the capitol
police board which i know we will hear
more about today
we owe it to the 140 capitol police
officers injured into all those
at the capitol who continue to suffer
the repercussions
we owe it to the officer beaten by the
violent rioters because he
literally placed his body in the doorway
to protect us
we owe it to the officers who lost their
lives we owe it to the american people
to figure out how the united states
capital
the preeminent symbol of democracy
around the world
could be overtaken by an angry violent
mob and we owe it to ourselves
colleagues
to believe enough in our democracy and
in the u.s senate
that despite our political differences
we will be constructive in this hearing
today
not just here to make political hay but
be constructive today
to figure out what went wrong and what
changes we can make
to ensure that the capital is safe for
us and the public going forward
chairman peters ranking member blunt
ranking member portman and colleagues
for me the bottom line is that we must
get the answers
and those answers are what will give us
the solutions
thank you very much
thank you uh madam chair it's been just
over
six weeks since our nation watched with
horror
as our capitol building was breached by
domestic terrorists who who sought to
use violence and
intimidation to overturn the results of
a free
and fair election this was a
shocking assault on our democracy and it
marked one of our
nation's darkest days
the united states has stood as a beacon
for the world
showing how democracy can thrive
on january 6th we saw just how fragile
many of our most
valued democratic principles including
the peaceful trance of power
is it's hard to express how deeply
grateful we are for the actions our
capitol police our sergeants at arms and
other law enforcement agencies do to
keep us safe every single day
and especially on that day too many of
our officers were
gravely injured or tragically killed
as they bravely fought back the
attackers
chief conte we are also indebted and
debit indebted to the d.c
metropolitan police department for their
valiant efforts to thwart the attack
d.c police often provide support to help
secure the capitol
but the officers under your command did
not hesitate
to come to our aid we are thankful for
the heroic actions of so many
who ensured this direct attack on our
democracy
failed but there's no question that
there were
colossal breakdowns in the intelligence
gathering and security preparations
leading up to the events of january 6
as well as during the coordination and
response efforts once the attack
got underway our goal today is to begin
to understand where those breakdowns and
failures occurred and to determine if
there are policy
and structural changes congress must
make to prevent a future
attack of this nature in my role on the
homeland security committee
i've worked to draw attention to the
rising threat of domestic terrorism
including the rise of insidious
ideologies of white supremacy uh
anti-government militias and now q anon
conspiracies these ideologies are
intertwined in numerous ways and on
january 6 we saw just how quickly they
can shift from online communities to
committing organized violent attacks
in the real world but the warning signs
were there
just a few months earlier in my home
state of michigan
law enforcement successfully stopped a
plot by anti-government militias
to kidnap our state's governor
we've seen an increase in violent crimes
over the last decade that are driven by
hateful ideologies and we saw the deadly
and tragic consequences on january 6
when the domestic terrorist threat was
not taken as seriously
as it should have been this is a
systemic and
leadership failure on the part of our
security officials from the fbi and
department of homeland security to the
security leadership on the ground in
capital
and it must be addressed domestic
terrorism is not a new threat
but it is an urgent threat it will
require serious focus to ensure that we
are doing everything we can to protect
the safety
and security of all americans
and i'd like to take a moment to remind
my colleagues that every senator here
today
took an oath to protect and defend the
constitution against all enemies both
foreign and domestic
as the committee's charged with
oversight strengthening homeland
security and maintaining
capital operations we have a solemn duty
to
thoroughly examine the security
breakdowns and make
needed reforms and i'm hopeful we'll be
able to work together
and carry out this responsibility in a
serious
and a non-partisan way and finally while
today's hearing is our
first on january 6th attack it will not
be
our last we will continue to seek
testimony and information from a range
of agencies and officials
who are involved in preparing for and
responding
to the events of the day for the u.s
capitol and for the entire region
the attack on january 6 was an
extraordinary event that requires
exhaustive consideration the american
people deserve
answers on why their capital was
breached
and i look forward to having a
productive discussion with our witnesses
in order to provide the american people
with those answers
thank you senator blunt
uh thank you chairwoman club church it's
been it's great to work with you
and chairman peters and senator portman
as we
move forward on this hearing on what
happened on
january the 6th and i think that'll
obviously also
require discussion of what happened in
the days immediately leading up to
january the 6th this hearing as senator
peters and you have both said
really the beginning of a series of
efforts that hopefully we can
approach in a bipartisan way that looks
for
solutions and ensures that the deadly
outrageous destructive attack that marks
such a sad day in our history
never happens again certainly the
officers officers who defended the
capital that day
deserve to be recognized and praised for
their valiant efforts and their
willingness every day to stand ready
to do what needs to be done to defend
the capital and those who
work there i'm certainly
grateful to them i'm particularly
grateful in this instance to the
metropolitan police department
and their really admirable response
to be here quickly to be here with
significant numbers
of people in the very short term and
within an hour to have
a an incredible impact on
what was going on here at the capitol in
a positive way the failures of the day
unfortunately were of the most serious
kind
uh senator klobuchar mentioned the three
officers whose lives were lost and
other officers who have
really had to deal with this in a
significant way you also have to
remember that
this was an event where the families of
our officers
were watching in real time uh on
television uh in an attack where they're
seeing
people that mean the entire world to
them
in this fight for their lives and fight
for our lives and the capital
three of today's witnesses former house
sergeant-at-arms
irving former senate sergeant-at-arms
stinger
and former chief of the united states
police capitol police son were all
charged with the protection of the
capital
on january the 6th we need to hear from
them
whether it was a failure of imagination
of what could go wrong
a failure of intelligence gathering
and dissemination a failure of
preparation which ultimately
led to this problem or maybe a
structural failure that just
is not designed in a way that it allows
us
to respond to an immediate crisis and
obviously we need to get that done i
want to hear from
chief conte of the metropolitan police
department
to learn about the department's role and
frankly to learn how
their decision-making process uh
appeared to be so much quicker
uh than the decision-making process we
could go through here
i believe it's important for everyone to
note that the attacks on
january the 6th did not prevent congress
from fulfilling its responsibilities
both
chambers reconvened that evening and
finished the certification of the
results
of the electoral college i think senator
klobuchar and the vice president and i
left the building about 4 00 a.m on
friday morning but we
did get our work done where the american
people and people all over the world
would have expected it to get done and
then on
the 20th we held an inauguration on the
same platform
that had been stormed uh three weeks
earlier
uh and uh two weeks earlier and carried
out one of
uh our most important uh aspects of our
democracy
the peaceful transfer of power i want to
thank my
colleagues from both the homeland
security
and rules committee for today's hearing
and the staff work that's gone into
getting
ready for today
ranking member portman thank you
chairman peters
uh chairwoman klobuchar ranking member
blount for the constructive comments
this morning uh in this business you
often
finish like you start and i appreciate
the fact that we're starting this review
by taking the politics out of it so we
can get to the bottom of what happened
i want to start by expressing my
gratitude on behalf of everybody for the
men and women
of law enforcement u.s capitol police
secret service national guard
metropolitan police department
the fbi and all the law enforcement
agencies who put their safety
on the line to safeguard democracy on
january 6.
as i said in the senate floor that night
it was thanks to them
the vice president pence members of
congress staff
and the capitol complex workforce were
protected
and we were able to complete our
constitutional duty of certifying the
election
it was important in my view that we sent
a clear message
that night to our constituents and to
the world that we would not be
intimidated
that the mob would not rule here but
that message could not have been
delivered without law enforcement
securing us
and our respective chambers seven
individuals lost their lives as a result
of the capital attack
including two capitol police officers
and a dc metropolitan police department
officer
we will never forget the service and
sacrifice of officers brian siknik
jeffrey smith
howard lievengood i knew officer
lievengood
i saw howie most days at his post at the
russell office building
his colleagues will tell you no officer
was more dedicated to the mission of the
capitol hill police department
the mission and duty to serve and
protect and i'm proud to have called him
a friend
we will never forget officer eugene
goodman and the hundreds of other
officers who were heroes on the front
lines
that afternoon that evening many of whom
sustained injuries
to honor that kind of sacrifice and
avoid future attacks
we have got to take a really hard look
at what happened on january 6.
the decision-making led up to that day
and
the decision-making that allowed the
capital to be to be breached
and overrun as the bipartisan media
advisory
announcing this joint hearing stated the
purpose today
is to examine the security failures that
led to a breach of the capital on
january 6
specifically the preparation and
response efforts
there are key questions that have to be
answered first some witnesses have
suggested there is an intelligence
failure
we need to know was there credible
intelligence about potential violence
when was it known and who
knew it second our witnesses have
differing accounts about requests for
national guard assistance
we need to know did the u.s capitol
police request approval to seek national
guard assistance
prior to january 6 and if so why
was that request denied we need to know
was the request for national guard
assistance on january 6 delayed
and why if that is true
and we need to know why it took so long
for the national guard to arrive
after their support was requested
third the capital was overtaken in a
matter of hours we need to know
whether capitol police officers were
properly trained and equipped to respond
to an attack on the capitol and if not
why not
and we need to know why the capital
complex itself was so vulnerable and
insecure
that it could be so easily overrun
my hope is that today we get clear
answers to these questions from our
witnesses
we need to know what happened and how to
ensure this never happens again it's
that simple
i'll be listening carefully as i know my
colleagues will to the testimony of the
witnesses before us
these events on january 6 showed that
while our democracy is resilient
our democracy at times will be
challenged we've got to be up to that
challenge
that certainly includes securing this
capital the citadel
of democracy that's something we can all
agree on
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator portman uh before i
introduce the panel it's important that
we hear from someone we all
believed it was important that we hear
from someone who was on the front lines
that day
and i'd like to recognize captain
karnisha mendoza of the u.s capitol
police
captain mendoza has been a member of the
capitol police
for almost 19 years with 13 years of
leadership experience
she currently serves as a field
commander in the special operations
division
where her duties include acting as a
field commander for significant security
incidents
she has served in various divisions
within the department including the
command center house division
and senate division before she joined
the capitol police she served as an
active duty soldier in the united states
army
and she has received various awards for
her work including her work
on recovery efforts during the pentagon
attack on 9 11.
born and raised in missouri senator
blunt
captain mendoza graduated from park
university with a bachelor of science in
criminal justice administration
she has two children on january 6
she rushed to the capitol when she heard
that her fellow officers
needed immediate help and assumed
command in the rotunda as she and her
colleagues fought to push back the
rioters
and ultimately drive them out of the
building captain thank you for sharing
your story today
thank you good morning
thank you for the opportunity to speak
before the committee today and thank you
all for your service to our country
my name is captain karnisha mendoza and
i've served with the united states
capitol police for 19 years
i take a lot of pride in my job prior to
serving with the capitol police
i served as an active duty soldier with
the united states army
my last duty station was split between
the pentagon and the washington area
criminal investigations division
i received various awards from the army
and the capitol police
to include an award for recovery efforts
during the pentagon attack
unfortunately i didn't save any lives
but there are certain lessons
that always stuck with me after 9 11.
one of those lessons is knowing the
unthinkable is always possible
so be ready so i always take my job very
seriously as 9 11 is always in the back
of my mind
with the capitol police i have served in
various operational
administrative and collateral
assignments i'm currently serving as a
captain in the special operations
division
where i have various responsibilities to
include serving as a field command
commander
and a field force commander for the
civil disturbance unit
throughout my career i have responded to
and managed various critical incidents
and events
from congressional and member security
related issues to shootings
and armed carjackings i have served as a
cdu field force commander for multiple
events
including the november 14th million mega
march
in my career i've been activated to work
demonstrations with various
controversial groups
and i've been called some of the worst
names so many times that i'm pretty numb
to it now
as an agency we have trained for and
handled numerous demonstrations
it's something we do on a regular basis
and it's something i've always felt
we've excelled at
during the million mega march multiple
white supremacist groups to include the
proud boys
and others converged on the supreme
court along with counter groups
the civil disturbance unit fought hard
that day physically breaking up fights
and separating various groups i
literally woke up the next day unable to
move
due to the pain on january 6 we
anticipated an event similar to the
million mega march that took place on
november 14th
where we would likely face groups
fighting among one another
additional civil disturbance units were
activated that day
i was working the evening shift and had
planned to report in at 3 pm
i was prepared to work a 16-hour shift
and assume field force commander should
the event continue into the evening
and overnight shifts it was
approximately 1 30 in the afternoon
i was home eating with my 10 year old
spending time with him before what i
knew would be a long day
when a fellow captain contacted me and
told me things were bad and that i
needed to respond in
i literally dropped everything to
respond to work that day early
i arrived within 15 minutes and i
contacted dispatch to ask her what
active scenes we had
i was advised things were pretty bad
i asked where assistance was needed and
was advised
of six active scenes
there was an explosive device at the
democratic national committee building
a second explosive advice at the
republican national committee
building and large hostile groups at
different locations outside the capitol
building
i advise the dispatcher i would respond
to the dnc since that building was
closest to where i was at the time
in route i heard officers at the capitol
building calling for immediate
assistance
so i proceeded past the dnc to the
capitol
as i arrived to the east front plaza of
the capitol i heard an officer yell
there was a breach
at the rotunda door and i heard various
officers calling for assistance at
multiple locations throughout the
building
many of the doors to the building were
not accessible due to the size of the
crowd
i was able to enter a lower level door
with the assistance of a capital
division officer
once inside the memorial door i
immediately noticed a large crowd
of possibly 200 rioters yelling in front
of me
since i was alone i turned to go back so
i could enter another door
but within the few seconds it took me to
walk back to the door i entered
there were already countless rioters
outside the building banging on the door
i had no choice but to proceed through
the violent crowd in the building
i made my way through the crowd by
yelling and pushing people out of my way
until i saw capital
police civil disturbance units and riot
gear in the hallway
they were holding the hallway to keep
rioters from penetrating deeper into the
building
i immediately jumped in line with them
to assist with holding the crowd of
rioters
at some point my right arm got wedged
between rioters
and the railing along the wall a cdu
sergeant pulled my right arm free and
had he not i'm certain it would have
been broken
shortly after that an officer was pushed
and fell to the floor i assisted the
officer to a safer location and got back
in line
at some point the crowd breached the
line officers worked so hard to maintain
civil disturbance units began to
redeploy to keep rioters from accessing
other areas of the building
i proceeded to the rotunda where i
noticed a heavy smoke-like residue
and smelled what i believe to be
military-grade cs gas
a familiar smell it was mixed with fire
extinguisher spray deployed by rioters
the rioters continued to deploy cs into
the rotunda
officers received a lot of gas exposure
which is worse inside the building than
outside
because there's nowhere for it to go i
receive chemical burns to my face that
still have not healed to this day
i witnessed officers being knocked to
the ground and hit with various objects
that were thrown by rioters
i was unable to determine exactly what
those objects were
i immediately assumed command in the
rotunda and called for additional assets
officers began to push the crowd out the
door after a couple hours
officers cleared the rotunda but had to
physically hold the door closed because
it had been broken by the rioters
officers begged me for relief as they
were unsure how long they could
physically hold the door closed
with the crowd continually banging on
the outside of the door
attempting to gain reentry eventually
officers were able to secure the door
with furniture and other objects
i'm proud of the officers i worked with
on january 6th
they fought extremely hard i know some
said the battle lasted three hours but
according to my fitbit
i was in exercise zone for four hours
and nine minutes
and many officers were in the fight even
before i arrived
i'm extremely proud of the united states
capitol police
i'm especially proud of the officers who
are the backbone of this agency and
carry out day-to-day operations
i know with teamwork we can move forward
the night of january 7th into the very
early morning hours of my birthday
january 8th
i spent at the hospital comforting the
family of our fallen officer
and met with the medical examiner's
office prior to working with fellow
officers to facilitate a motorcade
to transport officer siknik from the
hospital
of the multitude of events i've worked
in my nearly 19-year career in the
department
this was by far the worst of the worst
we could have had 10 times the amount of
people working with us and i still
believe the battle would have been just
as devastating
as an american and as an army veteran
it's sad to see us attacked by our
fellow citizens
i'm sad to see the unnecessary loss of
life
i'm sad to see the impact this has had
on capitol police officers
and i'm sad to see the impact this has
had on our agency and on our country
although things are still raw and moving
forward will be a difficult process
i look forward to moving forward
together as an agency and as a country
in closing i want to honor chief son's
leadership
i served under his command as a watch
commander for three years
and was able to personally see his hard
work and dedication
he was fully dedicated to the united
states capitol police
and he cared about every employee on the
department
i often hear employees on the department
praise his leadership and his ability to
inspire others
he's made a significant impact on our
agency
thank you chief thank you
thank you very much uh captain mendoza
for that beautiful statement and for
your work on behalf of our country
i'm going to give you the
bios on the other witnesses and then
senator peters will swear them
in our first witness today is robert j
conte acting chief of the metropolitan
police department of the district of
columbia
acting chief conte was sworn in as
acting chief of the mpd on january
2nd of this year he first joined the
department in 1989
as a cadet after being sworn in he
became a patrol officer before being
promoted to lieutenant
and leading the forces intelligence
branch in 2004 he was promoted to
captain and put in charge of the violent
crimes branch
after being promoted to second district
commander he joined the special
operations division
for the next decade acting chief conte
served in multiple leadership roles with
the mpd including his patrol chief
of patrol services south where he
oversaw several police districts
he was appointed as assistant chief of
the investigative services bureau in
march of 2018
acting chief conte is a graduate of d.c
schools
and holds a bachelor degree in
professional studies
from the george washington university
acting chief conte grew up in the carver
terrace community in northeast
washington d.c
our second witness today will be mr
stephen
a-sund mr sun served as chief of the u.s
capitol police
from june of 2019 to january 16th of
this year
mr sun joined the capitol police in 2017
as assistant chief and chief of
operations
prior to joining the uscp he spent
nearly 25 years with the metropolitan
police department
where he started out as a patrol officer
in 1990
from 1999 to 2006 he served as
mpd's special operations division and
helped plan several major events
including the 2001 and 2005 presidential
inaugurations after joining the mpd's
homeland security division
he rose through the ranks to become
commander of the special operations
division in 2011.
as commander of the special operations
division he served as lead planner
for both the 2009 and 2013
presidential inaugurations and many
other national security special events
he received his bachelor and master of
science degrees from john hopkins
and his master of arts in homeland
security from the naval postgraduate
school
our third witness will be mr michael
stenger
former senate sergeant at arms who
served in that capacity from
april of 2018 through january 7th of
this year
he joined the senate in 2011 as
assistant sergeant-at-arms for the
office of protective services
and continuity he has also served as
chief of staff
of the sergeant-at-arms and his deputy
sergeant of arms
prior to joining the sergeant-at-arms
office he was a 35-year veteran of the
united states secret service where he
served in many roles
including as the special agent in charge
of the washington field office
immediately before joining the senate he
served as
assistant director of the office of
government and public affairs for the
secret service
he graduated from fairleigh dickinson
university he is also a veteran
having attained the rank of captain in
the u.s marine corps
our final witness today is mr paul
irving
mr irving served as a sergeant at arms
at the u.s house of representatives
from january of 2012 through january 7th
of this year
he joined the united states secret
service in 1983
after briefly serving with the fbi he
served as head legal instructor for
constitutional law and criminal
procedure
at the secret service training academy
before joining
the presidential protective division
during the george h.w
bush and clinton administrations
following his white house service
he served as the assistant director for
congressional affairs
assistant director for government
affairs assistant director for homeland
security and assistant director for
administration for the secret service
he retired from the secret service in
2008 as assistant director
and worked as a private security
consultant until his appointment as
house sergeant-at-arms in 2012. he is a
graduate of the american university
university and whittier law school i
want to thank
our witnesses for appearing voluntarily
today and i look forward to your
testimony
it is the practice of the homeland
security and governmental affairs
committee to swear in witnesses so
if the witnesses would stand including
those joining us
virtually and raise your right hand
do you swear that the testimony you will
give before this committee shall be the
truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you god
thank you thank you may all be seated
you want to begin then chief conte sure
good morning chairman peters chairwoman
klobuchar
ranking members portman and blunt and
members of the committee
i'm robert j conte iii the acting chief
of police of the metropolitan police
department
the primary police force in the district
of columbia i appreciate this
opportunity to brief you
on the events of january 6 2021 a dark
day for our country
i would like to begin by highlighting a
few key facts to ensure the committees
and the audience understand the very
different roles
of mayor muriel bowser and the district
of columbia
including mpd and those of congressional
and federal authorities first
mpd is prohibited by federal law from
entering the capitol or its grounds to
patrol make arrests
or serve warrants without the consent or
request of the capitol police board
second the president of the united
states not the mayor of the district of
columbia
controls the d.c national guard scope of
the request
by the mayor must be limited to
supporting the district's local
jurisdiction and authority which
excludes entities
which excludes federal entities and
property third
since mayor bowser declared a public
health emergency last march
the district has not issued permits for
any large gathering
although the district and mpd take pride
in facilitating the exercise of first
amendment rights by all groups
regardless of their beliefs
none of the public gatherings on january
5th and 6th were issued permits by the
city
on the morning of january 6 mpd
was prepared to support our federal
partners with a first amendment assembly
that was held primarily
on federal land while continuing to
patrol
and respond to calls for service
throughout dc
based on our experience with prior
demonstrations after the election
we recognize that there was a
possibility of violence
especially after dark as smaller groups
of protesters
gathered with malicious intent on our
city streets
to be clear available intelligence
pointed to a large presence of some
of the same groups that had contributed
to violence in the city after
demonstrations
in november and december the district
had intelligence indicating the
potential for violent actions in the
streets of the district of columbia
in preparation for the anticipated
demonstrations
and the possibility of violence on city
streets
mpd was fully deployed on 12-hour shifts
the week of january 4th with days off
and
leave cancelled at mayor bowser's
request several area police departments
were on standby
in d.c and more than 300 members of the
national guard
were deployed on district streets
providing traffic control
and other services however these
resources were barely enough
to counter an event that had never
happened in the history of the united
states
a mob of thousands of american citizens
launching
a violent assault on the u.s capitol
the seat of our government in an attempt
to halt the counting
of the electoral ballots an essential
step in the peaceful transfer of power
in our nation
the mob sustained assault on the capital
precipitated an equally unprecedented
response
within capital police chief steve sun
issuing
an urgent request for mpd to come assist
in defending the capitol needless to say
when we received the call for help
mpd responded immediately within minutes
our members arrived at a chaotic scene
the violent mob had overran protective
measures
at the capitol in an attempted
insurrection prior to the arrival of mpd
officers
at the west front our objectives were to
one
stop the rioters from entering the
capitol building and remove those
that were already inside two secure a
perimeter
so that the capital could be cleared for
lawmakers three
enabled congress to resume their
sessions to demonstrate to our country
and to the world that our democracy was
still intact
and lastly once the third objective had
been accomplished
begin making arrests of anyone violating
the law
at 2 22 p.m a call was convened
with among others myself leadership of
the u.s capitol police
the national guard and the department of
the army
i was surprised at the reluctance to
immediately send
the national guard to the capitol
grounds
in the meantime by 2 30 pm the district
had requested additional officers
from as far away as new jersey and
issued
notice of an emergency citywide curfew
beginning at 6 pm
from that point it took another three
and a half
hours until all rioters were removed
from the capitol
90 minutes later at 8pm congress was
able to resume its critical work
and fulfill its constitutional duty
over the course of january the 6th and
into the early morning
of the 7th approximately hundred mpd
members
responded to the capital at least 65
mpd members sustained injuries
five people lost their lives on january
the sixth
as we reflect on that dark day we offer
condolences
to all of the grieving families
in closing i appreciate the opportunity
to highlight the heroism
of mpd officers who put their lives on
the line
to protect the capital congress and our
democracy
but to ensure the continued safety of
the district and everyone in it
we must be frank in looking at several
critical issues
this assault on the capital has exposed
weaknesses
in the security of the most secure city
in the country
the federal police forces in dc will be
re-examining
their security protocols given the risk
of both
foreign and domestic terrorism as the
chief of the district's
municipal police force i must think
about our preparations
not only for possible attacks but the
daily
impact of the changing operations of our
federal partners
as they harden targets in the federal
enclave other buildings in the city
under mpd jurisdiction may become more
likely targets
this concludes my testimony i am happy
to answer any questions
thank you very much mr sund
good morning chairwoman clovershaw
ranking member blount
chairman peters and ranking member
portman thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to testify before your two
committees regarding the attack
on the united states capitol that
occurred january 6th
i have been in policing for almost 30
years the events i witnessed on january
6
was the worst attack on law enforcement
and our democracy
that i have seen in my entire career i
witnessed insurgents beating police
officers with fists
pipes sticks bats metal barricades
and flag poles these criminals came
prepared for war
they came with their own radio system to
coordinate the attack and climbing gear
and other equipment to defeat the
capital's security features
i am sickened by what i witnessed that
day our officers fought valiantly
using batons shields chemical munitions
and pepper ball guns to hold back the
attackers
capitol police and responding law
enforcement agencies showed tremendous
restraint
by not using their firearms which would
have likely led to a more chaotic
situation
and a possible mass casualty incident no
civilian law enforcement agency
to include the united states capitol
police is trained or equipped
to repel an insurrection of thousands of
individuals focused on breaching a
building
at all costs i am extremely proud and
appreciative of the capitol police
officers
the metropolitan police department and
the other law enforcement agencies that
came to our assistance
a clear lack of accurate and complete
intelligence across several federal
agencies contributed to this event
and not poor planning by the united
states capitol police we rely on
accurate information from our federal
partners
to help us develop effective security
plans
the intelligence that we based our
planning on indicated that the january 6
protests were expected to be similar
to the previous maga rallies in 2020
which drew tens of thousands of
participants
the assessment indicated that members of
the proud boys white supremacist groups
antifa and other extremist groups were
expected to participate on january 6th
and that they may be inclined to become
violent based on the intelligence that
we received
we plan for an increased level of
violence at the capitol and that some
participants
may be armed but none of the
intelligence we received
predicted what actually occurred
extensive preparations were put into
place for january 6 that included
the full activation of the department
intelligence and information sharing
with our
federal and local partners and
department officials
implementing a significant enhancement
for member protection
extensive operational enhancements to
include
significant civil disobedience
deployment and an expanded perimeter
we also distributed additional
protective equipment for our officers
and coordinated and coordinated outside
agency support
as recent as tuesday january 5th during
a meeting i hosted with my executive
team
the capitol police board and a dozen of
the top law enforcement and military
officials from d.c
no entity including the fbi provided any
new intelligence regarding january 6th
it should be also noted that the
secretary of homeland security did not
issue an elevated
or imminent alert in reference to the
events at the united states capitol on
january 6th
we properly planned for a mass
demonstration with possible violence
what we got was a military-style
coordinated assault on my officers
and a violent takeover of the capitol
building
i know that the images we saw of the
officers battling for their lives
and the visuals on national tv had a
profound effect on the nation
the united states capitol police did
everything we could based on the
intelligence and available resources
to prepare for this event while my
officers were fighting
my post was in the command center
coordinating resources from numerous
agencies around the national capital
region
to provide critically needed support i
was also briefing the two
sergeant-at-arms
and working on establishing
accountability and priorities for the
incoming resources
as capital police and outside resources
began to re-establish
the security perimeter i responded to
the capitol building
to personally evaluate the situation and
brief the sergeant-at-arms
and leadership
i acknowledge that under the pressure of
an unprecedented attack a number of
systems broke down
one of the reported issues described by
officers was a lack of clear
communications and directions from
officials
it appears that the established incident
command for the capitol building was
overwhelmed
by the enormity of the situation and as
officials battling
insurrections as opposed to directing
the response
there have also been reports that some
officers may have felt confused
or let down during the attack
as an official who cares as much as i do
about my colleagues nothing is more
painful to me
these issues must be addressed through
new training policies and procedures
even our best efforts were not enough to
stop this unprecedented assault on the
capitol
however casting blame solely on united
states capitol police leadership
is not only misplaced but it also
minimizes what truly occurred that day
the focus going forward needs to be on
the efforts to improve intelligence
and the coordination of security
measures between all involved agencies
hopefully this will be part of the focus
of an independent after action committee
to look at all aspects of the january
attack on our nation's capital
in closing i want to again recognize the
heroic efforts of the capitol police
officers
who on january 6th outnumbered and
against the odds
successfully carried out their mission
to protect the members of congress
in the legislative process
i couldn't have been more proud to be
part of their team than the uscp mission
i'm available to answer any questions
you may have thank you
thank you mr sund mr stanger
chairwoman kobachar chairman peters
ranking member blunt
ranking member the national capital
region is a unique environment for law
enforcement
u.s capitol police conjunction with the
sergeants at arms
work to provide security of the capital
complex
and its population but there is a shared
responsibility with other law
enforcement
groups within the region sharing of
information and resources
paramount for success once assuming the
position of the senate sergeant-at-arms
enhancement of the working relationship
between my office and u.s capitol police
have been a priority i am a proponent of
the concept of intelligence-led police
this methodology can be used in
assessing threats to individual numbers
as well as threats to the campus as an
oral intelligence operations it is only
as good as the analyst assessing it
and that assessment is then placed in
the appropriate hands to take steps in
order to mitigate any threats
we have to be careful of returning to a
time when possibility rather than
probability drives security planning
the events of january 6 certainly reveal
the removal of intelligence should be
done
returning to the concept of possibility
driving security operations
may result in poor use of resources this
is the constant give and take of
security planning
there is an opportunity to learn lessons
from the events of january 6th
investigations should be considered as
to the funding and traveling what
appears to be professional
agitators first amendment rights should
always be considered
in conjunction with these investigations
law enforcement coordination in the
national capital region
should be reviewed to determine what can
be done in a more efficient productive
manner
intelligence collection and
dissemination
training and concepts on the use of
force must be consistent
disintegration should be accomplished
without regard to self-interest and
cause
it concludes in conclusion whenever you
prepare for a major event
it's always considered a possibility of
some level of civil disobedience
at these demonstrations and plan
according
events of january 6 went beyond
disobedience
this is a violent coordinated attack
where the loss
of life could have been much worse this
concludes my preparation
thank you mr stenger mr irving
chairman peters chairwoman klobuchar
ranking member portman
ranking member blunt and distinguished
members of the committees
thank you for the opportunity to appear
before you today
there has been a lot of press reporting
about me not all of it accurate and i
appreciate the opportunity to address
some of that today my name is paul
irving and i served as the
sergeant-at-arms for the house of
representatives for the past
nine years serving in that role was one
of the great honors of my life
and i counted a privilege to work with
speakers from
both political parties including speaker
boehner
speaker ryan and speaker pelosi
i'm a law enforcement officer by
training my professional career started
more than 40 years ago as an intern at
the department of justice
and then as a clerk at the fbi i later
became a special agent at the secret
service where i worked on two different
presidential protection details
and ultimately rose to the rank of
assistant director
like you i am profoundly saddened by the
events of january 6th
the entire world witnessed horrific acts
of violence and destruction
carried out by our very own citizens
against the global symbol of democracy
our seat of government i am particularly
saddened by the loss of life
which included which included three
officers
my heart goes out to all the families
that lost a loved one
we began planning for the protests of
january 6 in december 2020
the planning relied on what we
understood to be credible intelligence
provided by various state and federal
agencies
including a special event assessment
issued by the capitol police on january
third
the january third assessment forecast
that the protests
were quote expected to be similar to the
previous million
mega march rallies that had taken place
in november and december 2020
every capital police daily intelligence
report
between january 4 and january 6
including
on january 6 forecast the chance of
civil disobedience
or arrest during the protests as remote
to improbable
i relied on that intelligence when
overseeing the security plan put forth
by chief sun
the chief's plan took on an all-hands
on-deck approach
whereby every available sworn capital
police employee with police powers
was assigned to work on january 6th that
meant approximately 1200 capital police
officers were on site
including civil disturbance units and
other tactical teams i also understood
that 125
national guard troops were on notice to
be standing by for a quick response
the metropolitan police department was
also on 12-hour shifts
with no officers on day off or leave and
they staged officers
just north of the capitol to provide
immediate assistance if required
the plan was briefed to multiple law
enforcement partners
based on the intelligence we all
believed that the plan
met the threat and that we were prepared
we now know that we had the wrong plan
as one of the senior security leaders
responsible for the event
i am accountable for that i accept that
responsibility
and as you know i have resigned my
position
much has been said about whether optics
affected my judgment
in a january 4 telephone call with chief
sun
and senate sergeant armstanger about a
national guard
offer to incorporate 125 unarmed
national guard troops into the security
plan
the guard's purpose would have been to
work traffic control near the capitol
my use of the word optics has been
mischaracterized in the media
let me be clear optics as portrayed in
the media
played no role whatsoever in my
decisions about security
and any suggestion to the contrary is
false
safety was always paramount when making
security plans for january 6th
we did discuss whether the intelligence
warranted having troops the capital
that was the issue and the collective
judgment
at that time was no the intelligence did
not warrant that
if the chief or any other security
leader had expressed doubt about our
readiness without the national guard
i would not have hesitated to request
them
chief sund senate sergeant armstanger
and i were confident in the chief's plan
and i did whatever i could to ensure
that chief son had the support
needed to prepare and execute that
security plan
and on january 6 when i was asked for
authorization to request
national guard assistance i approved it
there are important lessons to be
learned from january 6th
i commend the committees for conducting
this proactive review
of the events leading up to and on
january 6th
i want to help the staff and members
make changes and improvements
and to ensure the tragedies of january
6th never occur again
i look forward to answering your
questions
thank you very much we'll now begin
questioning
i want to start out just to clear up one
thing by just
asking all of our witnesses a yes no
question
based on what we know now including the
recent department of justice indictments
do you agree that there is now clear
evidence that supports the conclusion
that the january 6 insurrection was
planned
and it was a coordinated attack on the
u.s capitol
just say everyone agree
yes okay would you agree that this
attack involved white supremacists and
extremist groups
yes yes okay would you agree that this
was a highly dangerous situation which
was horrific
uh but could have actually been worse
without the courage of the
officers that you commanded yes yes
thank you yes
okay so now let's look at what we knew
leading up to it or what you knew
leading up to it or what people that
worked for you knew leading up to it
uh we knew leading up to it that on
january
leading up to january 6 of president
trump sent nationwide tweets telling
people to come to washington on january
6
and saying be there will be wild
and according to public reporting by the
washington post
the fbi's norfolk field office issued a
threat report on january
5th that detailed specific calls for
violence
online in connection with january 6
including that protesters
quote be ready to fight and quote and
quote go there ready for
war end quote um i guess i'll start with
you mr sun when a critical
intelligence report is received by the
capitol police
from an intelligence community source
like the fbi
um who usually would receive it and i
guess i'll start with did you receive
this report
thank you very much for the question
ma'am uh actually just in the last 24
hours
uh was informed by the department that
they actually had received that report
it was received by what we call it's a
one of our sworn members that's assigned
to the joint terrorism task force which
is a
task force with the fbi uh they received
it the evening of the fifth
uh reviewed it and then forwarded over
to an official at the intelligence
division over at uh u.s capitol police
headquarters
and so you hadn't seen it yourself no
ma'am it did not go any further than
that
okay and then was it sent to the house
and senate sergeant-at-arms
i don't believe it went any farther than
uh from the start over to the sergeant
at the intelligence debate okay and mr
irving mr stenger do you
did you get that report
beforehand mr stanger did you get the
report
no okay mr irving i i did not
okay um
okay so i think that may have
contributed part to the lack of
information but i'll leave that um
for for the future now let's go back to
another report
the i know on january 3rd uh mr sun you
said in your written testimony that the
capitol police published intelligence
assessments
of the event including one on january
3rd
do you mostly rely on your federal
partners like the fbi to gather and
analyze
intelligence on potential threats to the
capital and members of congress
yes i think what's important to realize
as a law enforcement agency
we're a consumer of intelligence and
information that's provided
by the intelligence community the
intelligence community is 18 federal
agencies
that collect information do the
analyzing of the raw data
raw intelligence and then provide it to
us so we're reliant on that information
to be complete and accurate
but in that in that report we now know
according to your
testimony that tens of thousands of
participants were likely to send
on washington is that correct yes ma'am
okay and the january third memo
according to the washington post
made clear that supporters of president
trump see january 6 as the last
opportunity to overturn the results of
the presidential election
and that quote this sense of desperation
and disappointment may lead to more of
an incentive
to become violent is that correct yes it
is
um the article also quoted the memo as
stating that unlike previous
post-election protests the targets of
the pro-trump
supporters are not necessarily the
counter-protesters
but rather congress itself is the target
on the six
is that right that is correct and did
you have any indication that many of
these protesters might arrive
armed or that members of extremist
groups might be there
we knew members of extremist groups
would be there and there was
social media calls for people to come
armed yes
you've also said that at a january 55th
meeting with capitol police the
sergeant-at-arms and federal law
enforcement
military officials all present at the
meeting indicated that there was no new
intelligence
report for january 6. is that right that
is correct ma'am
but your testimony states that the
capitol police took a number of steps
after these assessments
like um what you said was the largest
number of civil
disturbance unit platoons possible
increasing dignitary protection coverage
coordinating with the d.c police and
ordering all hands on deck status for
capitol police
is that right that is correct ma'am we
took extensive uh efforts to prepare
for the events based on the information
much of which you just reviewed yes okay
good
so if the information was enough to get
you to do that
why didn't we take some additional steps
why didn't you and others involved to be
better
prepared to confront the violence
we we expanded our perimeter when we
expanded the perimeter
again we knew there was going to be some
maybe limited uh
violence but we did we expanded the
perimeter we took a number of steps to
outfit our personnel with
additional uh hard gear we developed a
plan for if we had
protesters that may be armed uh and that
was one of the reasons the expanded
perimeter and the uh
heightened risk that i went to the
sergeant arms and requested
the national guard and
but now you realize it wasn't enough
those security measures
is that right well that is you know
hindsight being what it is i mean
you look around the capitol right now
and you see the resources that are
brought to bear
based on the information we now know
from january 6th okay
mr sun you stated in your written
testimony that you first made a request
for the capitol police board
to declare an emergency and authorize
national guard support
on monday january 4th and that request
was not
granted that is correct ma'am your
testimony makes clear that the current
structure of the capitol police sport
resulted in delays in bringing in
assistance
from the national guard would you agree
with that that's one of the things we
want to look at
yes ma'am okay do you think that changes
are needed to make clear that the
capitol police chief has the authority
to call in the national guard
i i certainly do i think in exiting
circumstances there needs to be a
streamlined process
for the capital cheat uh chief of police
for the capitol police
to have authority okay and mr stanger do
you think that reforms
are needed to the structure of the
capitol police board to make that clear
i think uh a review of the capitol
police board and their statutory
authority is probably a
would be a good time to do this now
there's a lot of statues out there in
the capitol police board
that go back many many years
uh things have changed and it's probably
to make
the board a little bit more nimble it's
probably not a bad
time and an idea to take a look at
what's there it's probably an
understatement with what happened but
thank you uh mr irving your views
i would certainly agree with both chief
sund and
michael stanger i think a review would
certainly be warranted at this time
of the capitol police board mr sund your
written testimony states that you had
nor
no authority to request the assistance
of the national guard without an
emergency declaration of the capitol
police board
on what rule regulation or authority did
you base that view
uh i'd have to go back and look the
specific rule but it's a standard it's a
standing rule that we have
um i cannot request the national guard
without a declaration of emergency from
the capitol police board uh it's
it's kind of interesting because it's
very similar to the fact you know i
can't even give my men and women cold
water on
an excessively hot day without a
declaration of emergency
it's just a process that's in place um
and to be clear apart from the capitol
police board you also face delays in
getting authorization to bring in the
national guard from the department of
defense is that correct we'll be hearing
from them next week
yes ma'am that is correct um would you
agree that there were serious issues at
the pentagon that contributed
to the fact that guard troops did not
arrive at the capitol until about 5 40
that day
after most of violence had subsided i i
don't know what issues there were at the
the pentagon but i was certainly
surprised at the delays i was i was
hearing and i was seeing okay very good
and my last question just
as of all of you in addition to the
reforms of the
police board uh which are very clear
need to be made
any other suggestions that wouldn't
involve classified information you have
for us mr sund
as reference to uh some of the
recommendations
i would look at you know again you know
one of the big things that i think was a
contributing factor to this was
uh intelligence i think as you meet with
the intelligence community
and law enforcement in the intelligence
community we have a very good
relationship
i think the aperture just needs to be
opened up a little bit farther you know
like chief conte had mentioned you know
january 6 was a new day
it was a change of what threat we face
and i think getting them to open the
aperture and looking a little bit harder
and i think internally looking at some
of our policies procedures our processes
for how we handle special events how we
handle incident command
uh with stuff we can do and then looking
at
physical security of the building and
the grounds i think is going to be is
going to be critical
i know a lot of people have talked about
you know the fencing the open
environment i understand and i know that
goes way back
and members of congress like the open
environment i think there are
ways to develop a more secure
campus while keeping an open environment
but i'll leave that for more classified
or restricted
hearings okay thank you anything you
would add in addition just any other
thing you'd add in addition to
what the former police chief laid out
here mr singer
i would be very supportive without those
areas that
the chief mentioned i think he's right
on the money there
i think there's maybe another area of
use of force
uh that probably needs to be uh
coordinated
uh better in this in the region here
but certainly intelligence uh needs to
be taken a look at as
to how it works we have a lot of people
that we've ramped up since 9 11.
and i think maybe it's time to take a
look at how
how efficient it is on the gathering of
intelligence
and collection of intelligence thank you
i'm going to allow my colleagues to ask
that same question of
you mr irving and you uh chief conte
because i've gone over my time
thank you thank you
madam chair um mr sun i i you know
you've you've made the uh
or brought up the issue of intelligence
uh throughout your testimony and
the gaps that were there and then how we
need to to strengthen uh the
intelligence
but i was struck by the fact that you
said the fbi report
and my understanding is that that report
had some
fairly specific information that was
troubling uh that you said that their
report did get
sent to the capitol police that it went
to the folks
in the intelligence department uh but
then you were not aware of it
which raises a really big question
something coming in like that right
before an event
that i think is significant it does not
get to operational commanders who are
there to deal with it how did how
how can that happen how can you not get
that vital intelligence
on the eve of what's going to be in a
major event what
thank you sir i know that's something
that's going to be looked at i think
that information would have been helpful
to be aware of
again you know looking at the
information for the first time yesterday
it is strictly raw data it's raw
intelligence information that has come
in
seen on a social media post uh lots of
people postings on social media that
need to be
you know corroborated and uh confirmed
uh so it again
it's coming coming in as raw data so
please keep that in in mind but
you know i agree that's something we
need to look at what's the process and
how do we streamline that information
getting
to where it needs to go well i
understand it's raw data but it's the
eve of the event you're not going to
have time to to do the kind of analysis
that you would normally like to do
uh that is information that has to get
to you so that's clearly
a major problem and my question uh is
also related to
the uh report that was put out by
capitol police by your
your uh intelligence folks on january
3rd the intelligence division of the
capitol police
issued a internal report which
reportedly stated
uh and this is uh some of this has been
out in in the public domain
uh that uh instead of targeting counter
protesters
protesters as you've seen in the prior
events that occurred that you've
referenced
earlier that quote this is quote that's
been out in the public domain that
congress
itself is the target on the sixth
by trump supporters congress was the
target the report also mentioned that
members of the proud boys white
supremacist groups other extremist
groups would be in attendance and quote
again out in public sources
may be inclined to become violent so you
you have your own
report did you see that report that was
put out on the third
yes i did so how is not that a warning
of some extraordinary measures now i
understand you increased and you had
folks there and you increased your
presence
but how was not that not a real big
warning flag and if it was what exactly
did you do when you read that report
so that was one of the reports that
contributed to the fact that we
expanded our perimeter uh i reached out
uh you know looking at it i'd reach out
to the metropolitan uh police department
just knowing
even before that report knowing you know
what that um
extremists were likely to be there uh in
the previous reports for it that has
been called for on social media for
people to be armed
and talking with our partners over at
the metropolitan police department i
reached out to say hey we gonna be able
to provide us some support
and we coordinated that additional
support the morning of the uh of the
sixth
so yeah we did take all that in
consideration as we developed the
extensive security plans for this event
so you changed plans on january 3rd
after getting that report
we yeah we just just our perimeter we
did a number of things
uh for we actually were adjusting our
perimeter probably a little bit before
that as well
so that was happening before so we're
going to want to know more specifically
when you get that
and then of course i think we're going
to see you got additional
information from the fbi for example but
that did not get to you so i i
understand that
yeah the other thing that i think is
important for us to understand and i've
heard all of you mention this
uh in your in your testimony that this
was not just a uh
uh it was actually in response to uh
chair
chairwoman's uh klobuchar's question it
was not just a random
violent attack was actually coordinated
that you saw and i believe in your
testimony as well i'm gonna ask other
witnesses to respond to this too because
all of you mentioned that
how do you define coordinated what did
we actually see from these folks that
lead you to believe that it was
coordinated and i think in your
testimony now you just mentioned
military style coordination
so that would mean command and control
it would mean
understanding the layout of the capital
it may
mean knowing uh the internal operations
of
of defense perimeters of folks that are
engaged
talk to me what did you see that lead
you to believe that this was a
coordinated attack and i would like our
other witnesses to
to engage in that as well yeah i'm able
to provide you a quick overview of why i
think it was a coordinated attack
one these people came specifically with
equipment what
you're bringing climbing gear to to a
demonstration you're bringing explosives
you're bringing chemical spray such as
what captain mendoza mendoza talked
about
you're coming prepared the fact that the
group that attacked our west front
attacked her for west front 20 minutes
approximately 20 minutes before the
event we're at the ellipse ended
which means they were planning on our
agency not being at what they call full
strength
being you know watching the other events
saying hey that event's ending okay
everybody get on post they're going to
be marching our way
knowing that we may not be at full
strength at that time and then also the
fact that we were dealing with two pipe
bombs that were specifically you know
set right off the edge of our
uh perimeter to what i suspect draw
resources away
i think there was a significant uh
coordination with this attack
anyone else of my uh chief conte
i think you also believed it was a
coordinated attack oh absolutely
my view is from the day of the incident
uh i think there were hand signals that
were being used by several of the
insurrectionists
uh there were radio there was radio
communication
by several individuals that were
involved uh the coordinated use of
our chemical munitions to include uh
bear spray uh by several
people that were out there i certainly
believe it was coordinated uh
to chief sun's point regarding the uh
placement of the pipe bombs in the areas
their discovery uh prior to this event
all of those things and plus
uh adding to that what we know in
hindsight now
as a result of the ongoing investigation
that's being handled
by the fbi uh you know as they continue
to scrub
on social media i think we're learning
more and more and more this is clearly a
coordinated effort
real quick mr irving and then i'll ask
another question real quick mr ivy
based on the information provided by
chief conte
and i agree evidence put into a
coordinated attack
so we're looking at uh folks that were
coming out in in
intelligence reports that groups like
the oath keepers proud boys
others that were engaged these violent
extremist groups
which we clearly need to get collect
more intelligence on it'll be the
subject of another hearing that we will
do regarding this but if you look at
what the dog is now prosecuting 200
federal cases
uh the fbi has linked at least 40 to
extremist groups
59 to other defendants that have
connections on social media to
violent or extremist rhetoric conspiracy
theories uh
this is clearly an area that we've got
to focus on as to why
did we not have more information about
these
groups that were coming here planning
and usually you leave a trail when
you're planning
either that or you're real sophisticated
using encrypted
devices and other things but those are
things that we're going to have to be
looking at
clearly the national guard presence was
critical i know you're going to get a
lot of questions related to that but
chief kante in my remaining time just
a question yeah and you mentioned this
in your testimony but in an earlier
statement chief you stated that you were
stunned
by the by by quote the tepid
response of the army officials in
response
to chief sun's request for assistance
while the violent siege was
was uh escalating clearly here we got a
coordinate attack all of you saw this
immediately the way they were doing
i can imagine the conversations with the
national guard and chief you were
stunned by the tepid response could you
clarify that and tell us exactly how
those conversations went
yeah so uh just after some time after
two o'clock
or p.m i had left the west front of the
capitol after initially uh being at the
scene
assessing uh what was going on looking
at
uh just how violent uh looking at the
violent actions that were taking place
uh shortly thereafter there was a phone
call that was convened
between several officials chief son was
on the call uh
literally pleading uh for there were
several army officials that were on the
far i don't know
all by name who are several officials
from district government that were on
the scene
this chief son was pleading for the
deployment of the national guard
and in response to that there was not an
immediate yes
of the national guard is responding yes
the national guard
is on the way yes the national guard are
being restaged from traffic posts
uh to respond the response was more uh
asking about the plan
uh that you know what was the plan for
the national guard the response was more
focused on uh in addition to the plan of
the optics you know
how this looks with boots on the ground
on the on the capitol
and in in my response to that uh was
simply i was just stunned
uh that you know i have officers that
were out there literally fighting for
their lives
and you know we're kind of going through
you know what seemed like
an exercise to really check the boxes uh
and there was not an immediate response
uh
with the the when i asked specifically
uh
steve's son chief son was he requesting
the response
national guard and was that request
being denied the response was no
uh we're not the from the u.s department
of the army was no we're not
uh denying the request uh but uh in that
they were concerned they did have
concerns so i was just again just
stunned at that response
thank you
senator blunt thank you chairman uh
chief son if i have your testimony
correct this morning
i think what i'm hearing you say is
based on the intelligence
you saw on january the 3rd
after that on january the 4th you
decided this was going to be
a different kind of protest than we
you'd seen in november and december and
that's when you
asked for an expanded perimeter and
national guard assistance is that
correct
so the information we received yes it
was very similar to the previous
assessments it was just a little bit
more detailed we had been analyzing kind
of how we responded to the previous mag
of marches
and decided to expand the perimeter
really when you expand a perimeter as
large as we
expanded it it creates a large area you
have to defend
and that was the primary reason knowing
that these protesters were coming here
we were the focus of the protest
and the expanded perimeter and we knew
this was going to be a long day the
the um so did you know from the time you
expanded the perimeter that you were
going to have to have more
help like on all likelihood to defend
that parameter than uh
then your force would be able to provide
we we knew the additional
support would be we could we could
utilize the additional support yes
so why did you believe that you needed
the approval
of mr irving and mr stinger
to request assistance to the national
guard that's that's that's always been
the case we only
requested the national guard for very
specific events
usually the inauguration and that
requires a declaration of emergency from
the capitol police board
to utilize those resources do you know
if there's a statutory requirement
for that i could look into that and get
that to you as a follow-up if you do
like i don't i don't know that there
is but i i do know that if you get the
approval to expand the parameter and you
don't have the
assistance to do that that's obviously
a problem why didn't you contact the
third member of the police board
uh the architect of the capitol mr
blanton
uh thank you for that question sir um my
conduit to the capitol police board
was usually through the house and senate
sergeant arms they were the ones usually
having the communications with the
department especially law enforcement
related issues they're both law
enforcement and also the fact that mr
stinger at the time is the capital
police board
chairperson but usually outside the
monthly
capitol police board meeting that we'd
have unless it was a
issue specific to the architect
regarding you know building structures
something like that
my conduit was regularly the house and
senate sergeant arms
why do you think the architect of the
capital is on the police board
as one of the voting members and
providing oversight
but apparently not enough oversight that
you thought you needed to
involve him in the conversation uh like
i said
my usual conduit was going through the
the house and senate sergeant arms
you know that's already two people i got
to go to you wanna you know going to
three
you know in the future i guess if that's
something that's going to be you know
you know that will
implement then i will implement it but
that's i was just following my usual uh
course of action
so mr irving and mr stinger both let's
start with mr irving uh
why was the request for national guard
assistance not approved at the same time
you approved the expansion of the
perimeter
mr irving
i think you're muted mr irving
now you're definitely muted okay now you
should be fine go ahead
am i okay now yes thank you thank you i
apologize for that
senator i did not take the call from
chief sund
on the fourth as a request chief son
called me
to tell me that he was had received an
offer from the national guard to
provide us 125 unarmed
troops to work traffic control in the
perimeter of the capitol
shortly after that discussion i said
let's include
sergeant armstanger as chair of the
board and another
senior official with with quite a bit of
experience the three of us talked it
through
and during that call the number one
question
on the table was did the intelligence
support
did the intelligence support that
additional offer
for those 125 troops
did you did you discuss this with
anybody except
sergeant armstinger and chief send no it
was just this one phone call
and during that call we all agreed that
the intelligence did not support
the the troops
and collectively decided to let it go
michael stenger then said how about we
put him on standby
just in case and that's what we ended up
doing but
from what i remember everyone was very
satisfied that we had a
robust plan security plan that was
consistent with the intelligence that we
had at the time mr stinger why
why did uh why did you think that the
troops were on standby
uh they must have been standing way
away from where we needed them if it
took hours to get them here
what did that mean they were going to be
on standby
what i did was when i spoke to the chief
when the chief brought up to me
his attempt to get the national guard
and he apparently wasn't going
uh forward i suggested to him
that he reached out he knew the national
guard commander
his previous uh work in the uh
metropolitan police department i
suggested he reach out to the
national guard commander for a couple
reasons uh one of them was
i had either read in a paper or heard on
the news that the
national guard in dc was
rather reticent to engage
with the demonstrations this time
because of the
issues that had arisen during the white
house
uh demonstrations of a month ago
and that uh that we need to make sure
that the national guard was
engaged in this and that they would be
willing to
but do you think you did make sure that
they were engaged and would be willing
i'm going to have to go to another one
more question here
did you think they were engaged and
would be willing if called on
yeah that's what i think what i asked
the chief to turn
from the general all right mr mr irving
you said in your testimony that when
asked for national guard assistance you
approved it
mr sun stated that he asked for the
national guard assistance at 109
and you approved it was approved at 210
why would it take an hour to approve
national guard assistance on your part
in that moment of crisis mr irving
senator from my recollection
i did not receive a request for approval
for national guard until shortly after 2
p.m
when i was in michael stenger's office
let me get that straightened out mr sun
do you know when you asked for
national guard assistance was it 109 or
was it 2 pm
it was 109 sir 109 and who did you ask
for assistance at 109.
it was from uh mr irving i believe he
was in the company of mr singer at the
time as well
and mr irving why would you not remember
that
senator i have no recollection of a
conversation with chief son
at that time i was on the floor during
the electoral college
uh session and my
conversation with chief sund in that
time frame was
shortly before 1 30 when
i recall he was describing conditions
outside as deteriorating he may in fact
be submitting a request and
i carried that forward and um that was
as much as i can tell you i have no
phone record
call from chief sund
did you discuss that that request at 109
or whenever you got it with anybody else
or did you and mr stinger make that
decision then
no i did not get a request at 109 that i
can remember the first conversation i
had with chief sund
in that time frame was a rent was 128
130 and at that in that conversation he
indicated that
conditions were deteriorating he might
be looking uh
to for national guard approval and
approval of our
mutual aid agreements with local law
enforcement and
i went to mike stenger's office awaiting
an update
this is a time mr irving i'm i'm sure my
colleagues will want to follow up on
this because i'm
out of time but that's a time when the
difference in 130
and 210 or 109 and 210 makes a big
difference
one of the things i'm wondering and and
we don't have time for you to answer
this but i'm going to
tell you what i'm thinking here is in a
moment like this
if your focus is chiefly on
the safety of house members and i would
certainly understand that
and mr stenger's is chiefly on the
safety of senate members
maybe that's a problem here where the
board really
can't function as a board because you
have such diverse
areas of immediate responsibility but
whatever
happened here doesn't seem to me to be
an agreement
with the various time frames and i'm out
of time mr chairman
thank you senator blunt and i wanted
senator peters and are going to trade
off
uh chairing here with the votes and we
have a set order that all the center
staff have based on a melded
set of rules between the two committees
and i'd like to submit for the record a
written statement from the united states
capitol police labor committee dated
february 23
2021. thank you
without objection ranking member portman
thank you mr chairman
um first of all with regard to the
conversation we just had
on the discrepancies uh with regard to
national guard
assistance uh i would request that both
chiefs on you and uh mr irving provide
us with those phone records uh i know
there's
there's been some interviews that have
been conducted but i'm not sure we have
the phone records and that seems like
that would clear up some of the
confusion
i want to shift gears a little bit and
talk about preparedness
chief son in your testimony you talked
about
the need for better intelligence and
better coordination that was your
conclusion
and i i think that's true and certainly
everything we have learned indicates
that was
part of the problem but what about
preparedness
we've received information that prior to
january 6 capitol
police officers were not trained on how
to respond to
an infiltration of the capitol building
is that correct mr sund
when you talk about infiltration you
talk about a large insurrection like we
saw
on the january 6 no
and why not why wouldn't we be prepared
for
an infiltration of the capital given the
risk that's out there
um i would say to mr irving and mr
stenger
both of you who have had distinguished
careers with the secret service
um i i would i would ask you all just
give me a quick yes or no answer
does the secret service have training
regarding infiltration
as an example of the white house yes or
no
mr stagger
mr irving
senator i'll take that as a yes
if it's a no you okay mr stanger are you
a yes also
yes okay well it seems obvious that you
would have training on
responding to an infiltration um
so i think if if nothing else comes out
of this process
we've got to figure out how to deal with
again the the real
danger that is out there and it seems to
me the intelligence reports but also
just the
the previous demonstrations um
would indicate a need for that kind of
training
um let me ask you about something else
if i could
mr sun and that has to do with um
the u.s capitol police officers that i
saw on video and the world saw
fighting against this attack uh in
in street uniforms or soft uniforms uh
many of them did not have riot gear
i'm told by contrast you see police
department provides all those officers
such gear including
helmets shields gloves gas masks um
having seen those incredibly disturbing
videos and photographs of
your brave officers attempting to hold
the line to defend the capital
without that kind of riot here are all
capital police officers outfitted with
riot gear
no they're not sir they're not and
and why are they not so so if you look
at the way we outfit our our officers
and it'll probably be
very similar to i think you'll find with
even with metropolitan i've been with
metropolitan for a number of years
they'll have a certain number of
officers uh cdu platoons as they call
it's not the entire def entire force
that's outfitted to the
level one cdu with is the big protective
gear the helmets
uh things like that so we we outfit
a number of our we have seven cdu
platoons that we can activate
four of those platoons it's 40 people in
a platoon are activated to what we call
the level one the full cdu
gear and equipment it requires extensive
cost extensive training to keep that and
keep and maintain that
level for us a number of our officers
are posted
in interior post screening posts things
like that where they you know that gear
wouldn't do them any fight you know
wouldn't provide them any support
um so we have determined up until
january 6
that that number of cdu platoons had
sufficed for all the demonstrations that
we had dealing with
on capitol hill i would just say you
know obviously those officers who you
say had interior posts
needed it that day so it's not accurate
to say that they didn't need it
um but i know that you activated seven
of these civil disper
disperse this civil disturbance unit
platoons and um then only four of them
had riot gear um i don't know why you
would have a civil disturbance unit
platoon that didn't have riot gear
um but you've just testified that
that's true that only four of them had
it is that correct that is correct and
just one additional point since i've
been chief
i've actually pushed for every member in
the department to
to have riot helmets i had ordered those
back in september
that we had been looking at delays
because of code from the manufacturer
getting them delivered
and they actually just started being
delivered january 4th and distributed to
our officers
uh just days before this with limited
limited numbers being given to the
officers prior to this event
yeah too too late for for many of those
officers
chief conte the comment was made the met
pelton police does not all have rad
cares is that true i thought that the
met dalton police
department officers did have access to
rag here could you comment on that
yeah so we have seven platoons that have
the hardened hardened gear but all of
our officers
have ballistic helmets all of our
officers
have batons all of our officers are
deployed with gloves
as well and gas masks so our entire
department
are deployed with that level but when
you're talking about the hardened
part and all of the the other extras we
have seven platoons that have
the additional that's a different layer
of protection but every officer
has a helmet every officer has the
protective gloves every officer has the
baton is that correct
and gas mask that is gas mask
it appeared to
um the metropolitan police department
i'm told
that the capitol police officers did not
have the training and civil disturbance
tactics
that they had that's what i was told by
some of the interviews that we've had
chief conte is that correct
yes i have heard the same thing uh with
respect to the training of the
u.s uh capital police officers are all
of your metropolitan police officers
trained in civil disturbance tactics
we have uh platoons that are that are
trained for every uh
for for every patrol district and a
special operations
uh division uh some officers uh do not
have the civil disturbance
training on those officers generally
they work traffic duties or they work
assignments back in control
um chief sunderland
if i could add to one other thing all of
our officers who leave the training
academy
they get the basic civil disturbance
unit
training so all of our officers do get
the basic uh training but we might have
some members for example who've been on
for 30 years and they haven't been cdu
trained and they may work
you know back out of patrol district but
all of our members coming out the
academy they received the civil
disturbance
training uh mr sun is that true with
capitol hill police officers also are
they all trained in civil disturbance
tactics as they go through their
training
that was a process being implemented i
could check and let you know if that's
been fully implemented for new recruits
coming out of the academy that was one
of the initiatives i was working on
so we were working on that but um as far
as you know this training was not being
provided even for new officers much less
for those
i believe i believe the new officers
coming out were but i just need to uh
confirm that
yeah i i think the the bottom line here
is that unfortunately our officers were
not
given the proper training with regard to
infiltration of the building or the
complex with regard to
dealing um with civil disturbance
and and they didn't have the equipment
necessary to push back and most
importantly
to protect themselves so my hope is that
again
one of the ways that this
joint hearing and this committee report
can be helpful is to bring the capitol
police department up to speed
uh and look i appreciate the sacrifice
and the bravery of that day
but i think we also owe it to those
officers to provide them the training
and the equipment they need
to protect themselves and to protect the
capital thank you mr chairman
thank you ranking member the chair now
recognizes senator leahy
thank you uh mr chairman i i'd like to
follow up on what senator portman said i
i agree with his concerns but i might
ask a question from the appropriations
committee and i know time is limited so
these could be yes or no answers
the appropriations committee has always
worked in a bipartisan fashion to get
money to
the uh to the police so mr sun
yes or no the appropriations committee
ultimately the congress had met your
request for salaries and operating
expenses in every fiscal year is that
not correct
yes sir thank you and mr steger
the appropriations committee and
ultimately the congress has met your
request for
salaries in operating expenses every
fiscal year is that correct
i don't hear an answer so i asked mr
irving
serving the appropriations committee and
ultimately the congress has met your
request for salaries
and operating expenses in every fiscal
year is that correct
yes that that is correct mr steger
yes that's correct sir thank you very
much
um
so i i have to think that we had in
not that we had inadequate resources
but a failure to deploy the people
that we were supposed to i look at those
who
appeared i looked at the lives that were
lost the
uh police who fought who
protect our our capital and we saw this
as a
violent and i'd say planned and
organized attack on the united states
in the united states government by
domestic terrorists
i hope they're all going to be
prosecuted as fully
as they can but those uh
when we see people encouraging them
including from the
former president of the united states
who urged his followers to fight and to
show straight
i i really wonder why we didn't take
this seriously enough
to be prepared for them the hours it
took to bring in the
uh national guard and everything else
so i i read uh mr sutton i read your
detailed letter to
speaker pelosi but
you said there wasn't enough
intelligence shared but in your same way
you stated
the intelligence assessment i'm quoting
here
indicated that members of the proud boys
white supremacist group antifa and other
extremist groups were expected to
participate in january 6th event
they may be inclined to become violent
how much more intelligence
we need than that
yes sir that is that is correct that is
what the intelligence assessment said
it was very similar to the intelligence
assessments that we had for the november
and december uh mega marches uh the
intelligence assessments that we had
developed for the january 6 event
all the way up uh until january 6 we're
all saying very much the same thing and
that's what we had planned
for we had planned for the the
possibility of violence
the possibility of some people being
armed not the possibility of a
coordinated military-style attack
involving thousands against the capital
violence and arm strike me as a pretty
strong
uh pretty strong thing and i
would suggest that everybody get
together and look at the future because
if you have something that goes on for
months
the president calling them everybody
else calling them
i'm worried that there was not more
there
i think until we ruled out the hate and
throw the rioters to the door that day
no fence or tank or barrier is going to
provide
the safety we need um
i want safety but also talking about
peterborough franklin says give up
those who give up essential liberty to
approach a little temporary safety
deserve neither liberty
nor safety but
i know a vote is on and before i close i
do want to commend
chief conte for your swift response
i you don't have an easy job in charge
of protecting a city as large as
washington d.c
and balance the delicate balance with
other dozens of other
law enforcement but i think that uh
i commend the two chairs and ranking
members for
holding this hearing will hold more in
appropriations
but we're going to look very closely at
the request this year
and say what do we do if we have another
one of these
i thank you you back my time
thank you senator leahy uh chair
recognizes
senator johnson thank you mr chairman i
want to start off by just thanking
our law enforcement witnesses for your
service i know
there's 2020 is hindsight it's pretty
easy to money
money morning quarterback and i want to
make sure that we we guard against doing
so
certainly what i've seen from testimony
it seems like there's a fair amount of
thought
a fair amount of due diligence went into
this so again i appreciate your service
i also want to say i find the videos uh
as you said chief son sickening uh
the violence reprehensible the racial
slurs repugnant
and i want to make sure the perpetrators
the the people that are engaged in the
violence
uh are prosecute the full extent of the
law
i've got a long list of questions which
this format really doesn't
lend itself to asking so what i will be
doing is preparing a letter for the
committee chair and hoping that they
will
ask those questions and investigate
these issues that
that i'll be listening but what i want
to do in terms of
asking some questions i want to start
out by reading excerpts from what i
thought was a very interesting
eyewitness account by
j michael waller he is
a senior analyst for a strategy at the
center of security policy his areas of
concentration
include political and psychological
warfare and subversion he's a former
professor and instructor at the
institute of world politics
at the naval post graduate school he's a
current lecturer at the john f
kennedy school special warfare center at
fort bragg
he wrote a piece titled i saw
provocateurs
at the capitol ride on january 6th and
he he basically arrived on scene by 11
30 from union station
and i'll just start reading about 11 30
i walk from near union station
and noticed a small number of capitol
police dressed in full riot gear
with shin guards and shoulder guards
then i walked
up pennsylvania avenue toward an empty
freedom park
he noticed that the speech had broken up
and so
a crowd was was walking down
constitution avenue they he
joined them at 13th street but he said
that the mood of the crowd was positive
and festive of the thousands of people i
passed were who passed
me along constitution avenue some were
indignant and contemptuous of congress
but not one appeared angry or incited to
riot many of the marchers were families
with small children many were elderly
overweight or just plain tired or frail
traits not typically attributed to the
riot prone many wore pro-police shirts
or carried pro-police black and blue
flags
although the crowd represented a broad
cross-section of americans mostly
working-class by their appearance and
manner of speech
some people stood out a very few didn't
share the jovial friendly earnest
demeanor of the great majority
some obviously didn't fit in and he
describes
four different types of people plain
closed militants agents provocateurs
fake trump protesters and then
disciplined uniform
column of attackers i think these are
the people that probably plan
this he goes on the d.c metropolitan
police were their usual professionally
detached cells
standing on curbs or at street crossings
and exchanging an occasional greeting
from marchers
when we crossed first street northwest
to enter the capitol grounds where the
capitol police had jurisdiction
i noticed no police at all several
marchers
expressed surprise the openness seemed
like a courtesy gesture from congress
which controls security
that appearance of low threat level made
no sense yet no capitol police appeared
anywhere from what we could see now
again i'm taking these these excerpts
uh in order but there's a lot more to
this piece
what looked like tens or even hundreds
of thousands of people surged down the
avenues as far as one can see
but almost everyone seemed talkative and
happy no police could be seen on the
platform for now
no police could be seen anywhere people
kept surging in from constitutional
avenue and the plaza quickly filled up
and overflowed on the lawn
everyone squeezed closer and closer
together with most in high spirits
some trouble began up in the front near
the base of the inaugural platform
itself
but we could not see what was happening
then something happened
at the front of the crowd it seemed like
a scuffle but from 40 feet back i
couldn't see
people started chanting usa usa and
other slogans
for a few seconds i saw what looked like
police in a tussle with some of the
marches up front
what appeared to be an organized group
in civilian clothes
this organized group are the cell i
would call the plainclothes militants
that fit right in with mega people
suddenly energy surge from the front of
the crowd is the anti-riot police
above on the inaugural platform visibly
tensed up
one fire to tear gas canister not at the
plainclothes militants to the front line
but into the crowd itself then another
flash grenades went off in the middle of
the crowd the tear gas changed the
crowd's demeanor
there was an air of disbelief as people
realized that the police whom they
supported
were firing on them what are you doing
we support you someone yelled
all of a sudden pro-police people felt
the police were attacking them
and they didn't know why more tear gas a
canister struck a girl in the face
drawing blood
the pro-police crowd went from disbelief
from confusion
to anger i'll stop there the last five
pages uh
is titled provocateurs turn unsuspecting
marchers into an invading mob
so i'd really recommend everybody in the
committee read this account
and i've asked it to be entered into the
record but chief said i want to ask you
is one of the re the house managers made
a big deal
that this was predictable this was
foreseeable which i don't believe
do you believe that what happened the
breach of the capital did you believe
that's foreseeable and predictable
no i don't nor do if you look at some of
our other partner agencies i think uh
acting chief conte actually made the
statement that the breach of the capital
was not something anybody anticipated
uh nor do i think some of our federal
partners expected it i don't think
secret service would have brought up the
vice president if they expected it
is part of that because of what you'd
experienced in the past what this
mr waller experience is the vast
majority of trump supporters are pro-law
enforcement and the last thing they
would do is violate the law
i i will say that story you know
information i've received from some of
my officers were
they were trying to prevent people from
coming into the building and people were
showing up saying hey where police
led us through and still wanting to
violate the law to get inside the
building so
you know again i've got a long long list
i just want to close with the two
former sergeant of arms um
i knew this committee these committees
were going to start an investigation i
waited a couple weeks
i didn't see any letter go out oversight
letters so i wrote my own on the 21st
and i just have a question for both the
former sergeant of arms did you get my
letter my oversight letter with with
my questions
i did not i did not receive your letter
i left town right after
i resigned but i certainly look forward
to working with you
and your staff to answer your questions
okay well if you give us an address
because
we sent it to the acting sergeant arms
huge that acting sergeant orange won't
even let us know whether they pass that
letter along to you apparently they
didn't
uh mr stenger did you receive my letter
uh i don't recall it senator but uh i
might it might have come i don't recall
chief son one last question for you do
you do you regret resigning
yes i do sir i certainly do regret
signing all right resigning i
uh i love this agency i love the women
and men of this agency and i regret
the day i left well mr irving mr stinger
i i really wish you'd respond you know
first of all
look look for my letter and i'd like an
answer to that as quickly as possible
thank you
thank you senator johnson um we're
waiting for senator warner
and any other member i see senator rosen
would you like to go ahead
because you're the first member on
senator rosen
perfect thank you very much senator
klobuchar and uh
thank you everyone for being here today
uh
and uh um springing this hearing is much
needed and i think it's the first of
many
but i'd like to start off by expressing
that my thoughts are with the brave
capital police officers
they put their lives on the line to
protect us on january 6
and their heroic actions like the ones
of eugene goodman
they redirected those violent rioters
away from us
they're going to forever be embedded in
our minds and we know that so many of
these courageous men
and women they're really hurting in the
aftermath of the insurrection
and i've been particularly heartbroken
to hear about the death of
capital police officer howard lehmann
good he's been
protect he was protecting the senate
since 2005. he was stationed by the door
of my russell office my prayers are with
him
his family and his loved ones but you
know when the
insurrectionist when they came to storm
our capital on january 6 they came
armed not only with weapons but also
with hate
mere weeks before international
holocaust remembrance day the world
watched in horror as a rider inside
the capitol proudly wore a camp
auschwitz
shirt as he and others violently pushed
forward on the house and the senate
floors
all the while the riders and wavy
confederate flags
are hanging nooses on the front lawn
they're verbally assaulting a jewish
reporter outside the capitol
saying you are cattle
that refers to cow cars that used to
transport that were used to transport
jews
to nazi death camps during the holocaust
this violent attack in the capital uh
featured followers from the anti-semitic
humanon conspiracy theory so mr conte
on january 4th metro police department
arrested enrique rio leader of the
racist
anti-semitic proud boys hate group fbi
claims the next day is shared with mpd
concrete intelligence about extremist
plans
for violence on january 6 including
specific
threats on members of congress maps of
the tunnels
under the capital complex if mpb was
tracking extremist potentially violent
white supremacist activity
then what exactly did you know on
january 5th
and why didn't you alert anyone
thank you for that question uh what the
fbi sent now
on january 5th was in the form
of an email i would certainly think that
something as violent as an insurrection
of the capital
uh would warrant um you know a phone
call or something
but as chief son mentioned earlier
the information that was sent was on uh
it was uncooperative uh information
it was raw uh information that we had uh
that we received
through the same lines through the jttf
uh that information uh was not fully
vetted and had not been sent
through the chains of the metropolitan
police department what the metropolitan
police department
was prepared for was the larger violence
and demonstrations that we expected to
see in our city
that's fine i have i have to ask mr sun
the same question now what did you know
as of tuesday night january 5th because
i i have a follow-up for both of you
on this one so quickly mr sun what did
you know on january 5th
and were you alarmed or not alarmed what
did you expect
uh so yeah i was uh you know i was
concerned we had the intelligence that
was coming out the intelligence that
we'd be planning for
again keep in mind the intelligence
assessments that we had developed
at the end of december the beginning and
the one for january third were very very
similar
they just provided a little bit more uh
specificity so we had already been
planning for
the threat for violence the threat for
armed possible people uh protesting
and that's what we're um planning for
now if you're referring to the
norfolk letter again uh i just became
aware that the department was aware of
that
24 hours ago so on the 6th or the 5th or
the 4th
i was not aware that memo existed so so
you're saying that there's a breakdown
between you
and the fbi because we have rallies
protests and things happen in washington
all the time how many do you
could both of you just maybe give a
guess how many do you
think are usually with armed
insurrectionists or come heavily armed
out of the
uh hundreds perhaps thousands of rallies
that we see in washington
uh through the through the year we know
the last
three uh incidents the first two mag
around men and
women of the metropolitan police
department uh recovered firearms from
several people who were attending
uh the demonstrations uh at the first
mega rally as well as
the second one aside from that those are
have been really the only uh
the only demonstrations what we've seen
individuals coming on
well do you think this was an
intelligence breakdown or a resource
issue
i think that the intelligence uh has not
did not make it where
it needed uh to be uh in terms of the
fbi
you think the fbi did not raise us to
the level they needed to with
metropolitan police department
in your mind we received it in the form
of an email that came as
an alert bulletin at seven o'clock p.m
the day before
to help posture our posture of the
metropolitan police department
again i think uh you know it's reflected
in our deployment
in terms of not just the uh national
guard that was deployed
but as well as other officers from
surrounding jurisdictions
that reflected the seriousness that we
took with respect to the threats that we
were expecting to see in the city
mr um mr sund can you tell me do you
think this was a
um a resource issue or intelligence
breakdown or something else if you
uh be brief because this is very
important
yes ma'am i'll be very brief was part of
my introduction i think it was it was
more than just the norfolk letter i
think we need to look at the whole
entire
intelligence community and the view they
have on some of the
uh domestic extremists and the uh effect
that they have i looked this as a
intelligence problem that impacted this
event yes
so what information would you be would
you have had to have heard
to have raised up the flag
to to get more resources for the capitol
police because
thank goodness i mean we we saw loss of
life and thank goodness there wasn't
more but one is too many so what
what is your threshold then what should
be the threshold
to protect the capital and protect your
officers
i did i reach out to the washington d.c
police to coordinate resources
and i did also go to the uh both the
house and senate sergeant arms to
request the national guard
um and mr conte i think i have five
seconds
and we can take this off the record but
i believe that there's planning uh there
are some plans by q anon for something
to happen at the capitol on march 4th
i want to hear what steps we're taking
to protect the capital
uh on march 4th from any
uh any more violent extremists thank you
okay we'll have you talk to him about
that later cause senator warner
has arrived via video and i also want to
mention senator peters will work with
our witnesses
for restroom breaks and the like and let
us know so that
we don't want to take a long break but i
can imagine you need a break at some
point here so
uh senator warner thank you madam
chairman
and thank you to the witnesses um
for for appearing today
um you know we we've talked a little bit
about the
deployment or lack of deployment of the
national guard
um and one of the questions i guess
mr sund uh or frankly or chief conte
you know the fact that we the district
did not have the ability to um
uh bring the guard to the table
uh because of um frankly that they're
not a state and
mayor bowser is not treated i think in a
in a totally fair fashion in this
um this may be outside your lane but um
her inability to to bring the guard to
the table and actually any of you on the
panel can answer this
that to me is a reflection of the
disempowerment of the district
on a going forward basis at least in
terms of being able to deploy the guard
shouldn't the mayor of the district of
columbia have the ability to to do that
without
all the additional hurdles they have to
go through in terms of federal check
checklist
yes i absolutely agree with that
does anybody else want to answer on that
question as well
yes sir i'm happy to add in i think we
we have an established process for the
capitol police to
to make the request through the capitol
police board that is also
equally as effective well again i
i feel like the long-term
discrimination against the district
we've seen it in some of the coveted
legislation where they
did not receive the same kind of level
of support that um
other states did we saw it play out real
time
in terms of on january 6 the the
hurdles from the previous administration
i actually have concerns whether
the deployment of the guard was
affirmatively slowed down
um i hope that we in the congress will
uh as a supporter of d.c statehood i'd
like to see that move forward but
even short of that trying to ensure that
the mayor has
appropriate powers going forward i know
there were some questions already raised
about
um the fbi
and whether that the intel that came out
of the norfolk fbi office was either
ever fully relayed to all of you
individuals
but can you talk more generally about
the fbi's responsiveness sharing of
intelligence
i had a number of conversations i called
director ray
on monday the 4th
trying to express concerns that there
might be this kind of activity i never
expected this level of violence
i had a number of conversations with
senior fbi
leadership on the 5th through the sixth
um uh i can't believe it was
i don't think even the thought yeah i
could have been fully informed of all of
what was going to come to pass but i i
felt like
the fbi felt that we they were in better
shape in terms of
intel and preparation than what came to
be the case and
i'd like each of you to comment on how
well you felt that the
fbi did in terms of sharing intelligence
and then coordinating when the actual
activities of the sixth
played out so
i'll go ahead um did you you want me to
address that first
yeah i mean i can't see where you all
are so every one of you can take a crack
at that
i'll go ahead and start first uh i think
the relationship we have with the fbi is
outstanding
i think in my time with metropolitan and
my time here
we've seen nothing but the relationship
get better the construct that we have
that's very similar to some of the other
major cities is having the joint
terrorism task force being involved with
that
the the information we're getting in uh
is is good
i think the the process and and having
like i said earlier
the wider lens of what information is
being collected
maybe looking at the agencies that are
consumers of their uh
information and what their intelligence
collection requirements are is something
we need to look at
but i think you know getting that
information in and then having it
processed
and pushed forward in an effective
manner is something we need to look at
i would say uh on the sixth when this
started happening
you know immediately the fbi you know as
being a partner of ours
established a process where with capital
police and fbi police we can begin to
analyze video footage analyze other
evidence to begin going out and making
arrests
of the individuals that had created the
insurrection of the capital
if we get the balance of the panel to
respond yeah sure
uh i i would echo what what chief son
just mentioned
uh we've had a great working
relationship with the fbi uh i think
it's a whole
of intelligence approach not
specifically just the fbi when we have
something
as significant as what occurred here at
the u.s capitol uh if
you know if there is information
specific information
out there that our government is
responding uh
to i would think that something of that
nature would rise to the level
of more than just an email on the sent
to law enforcement agencies that should
be
a larger more involved conversation
about specifics
on that you know not just some of the
unvetted raw information that's out
there we see a lot of that but i think
it's more of a whole
intelligence approach and that's
specifically the fbi they are great
partners to the northern police
department
thank you let me just um
i don't know if any of the other panel
members want to
want to add any comment on that let me
just
say that this is my concern is that um
in in virginia we've seen these kind of
anti-government extremists
uh take to the streets of
charlottesville in 2017
resulting in the death of heather heyer
we see
the same kind of uh groups come to
come to the forefront and on january 6th
i think this is an ongoing uh threat to
national security uh i fear at times
that while the fbi and others have
pointed this out that it didn't get
the level of of
serious review that it should have
with the prior administration i felt at
times that they
did not want to take the information
that was coming out of the fbi i hope on
a going forward basis we're going to be
able to be
more coordinated in terms of taking on
anti-government extremism
whether it comes from the left or the
right this is a real
ongoing threat i can tell you from our
intelligence committee
that we've seen that many of these
groups have connections and ties
to anti-government extremist groups in
europe
uh where they've taken a great precedent
i know my times expired
madam chairman but uh this is something
we need uh more work on thank you for
watching
um thank you very much senator warner we
look to working with you
and the intelligence committee on this
um next will be senator lankford and
after that senator carper
thank you uh son i want to try to
validate something there's a letter
that's in the public domain not this at
this point that's an eight page letter
that was written to speaker pelosi
that is attributed to you to try to
explain the events of that day
are you familiar with that letter in the
public domain and is it accurate yes it
is sir
so in the letter itself um you described
several things in this in the details
and the timeline on it
uh can you tell me why you wrote this
letter to speaker pelosi
what was the purpose of the letter i i
feel at the time
uh i resigned i had limited
communications with my uh with my
department
i know my department was getting ready
to go and testify at some of the initial
uh committee hearings
and i think that she had called for my
resignation without full understanding
of what we had prepared for
what we had gone through uh that
i think she deserved to read you know
firsthand
what we had prepared for and what uh you
know what i dealt with that that
for that sixth okay that's helpful uh
you had said in this you talked several
times about thousands of
well-coordinated well-equipped
violent criminals and described them
with climbing gear and all the things
that you've also testified here
you you also mentioned this letter about
the pipe bombs that were located
uh that the first word will come at 12
52 that a pipe bomb had been located at
the republican national committee
headquarters
how was that located who found it and
why was that particular moment the
moment that it was found
i i don't know why that was a particular
moment that was found uh i believe it
was an employee of the republican
national committee
that had uh located it in the rear of
the building that had called it into
capitol police headquarters
you had mentioned before that you
thought this was part of the
coordination that there were several
that were out there that would take away
resources at that exact moment
but there's no way to know that they
would find it at that exact moment i'm
glad they did find it they found another
one at the democratic
headquarters as well at 150 and you
document that as well
but you had to send quite a few
individuals to be able to go to the rnc
and the dnc
to be able to go deal with those
explosives that were planted there is
that correct
that that is correct and just for your
information the rnc
pipe bomb that was one that was really
run by uh capitol police the dnc
metropolitan ended up taking that and
running that so
we can run two concurrently that
resulted in the evacuation of two
congressional buildings
the um canon house office building as
well as one of the library of congress
buildings
so it took extensive resources so the
assault in the capital is not what
caused the evacuation of those buildings
the discovery of those pipe bombs is
what caused the evacuation of those
that is correct sir there's been quite a
bit of conversation today
and quite a few members here that have
talked about the national guard and the
length of time that it took to be able
to go through the bureaucratic process
to be able to get them deployed
i i i do think that needs to be
shortened obviously in a deployment
structure
and the complexity of the bureaucracy
here but it seems to be a
misunderstanding
on this diaz of some individuals
describing the national guard as if
they're the riot police
that can automatically be called out
they're not were you expecting them to
be like a rapid response swat team at
this point
what's a typical response from the
national guard to be able to call them
out when they are not currently
positioned
i believe the typical response once they
are they're approved is approximately
two hours
okay but then the approval process is
obviously multiple hours to do that or
multiple days to do that
you had started that process several
days before and making some requests
so that that is correct as far as the
process you know my
my initial request was over to mr irving
it was actually an in-person request on
the
uh on the fourth uh and it was until the
evening of the fourth that i talked to
general walker that he informed me that
uh if needed because mr stinger wanted
me to ask him if they could lean forward
they could get 125
right if needed in a fairly fairly quick
fashion once approved
so that's when what leading into january
6 when we made the initial request at
109.
but that 125 individuals from the
national guard that were prepared to be
able to move faster because they were in
streets and different places
doing traffic duty at that point you had
already been informed that the
city of washington dc and the mayor's
office had made a request to dod and dod
had approved it that none of them would
be armed
none of them would be have heavy gear on
there would be no military vehicles
that'd be available to them they had to
use
unmarked vans and other government vans
and there would be no helicopters that
would be used
those were prohibited that day for those
125 individuals that were already on the
street is that correct
so just for correction at the time no i
did not know that was the restrictions
being placed on them
and uh two when i talked to general
walker the evening of uh
the fourth which was monday evening the
125 he was going to give us were
125 that were doing coveted relief for
the district of columbia not assigned to
the traffic post
okay so the individuals that were
assigned to traffic judy
had no weapons had no military vehicles
moved had no overhead
uh visual on anything that had all been
requested no from the city of washington
dc
and then for the other individuals that
could be assigned to you as a rapid
force those are folks that were
currently doing covet duty
so you had no swat team this description
is
very interesting to me around this diaz
that people think that suddenly the
national guard just bursts in
uh and is ready to go on that that's not
what the national guard is
pre-positioned to do
that that is correct uh anytime we
request the national guard they've been
in an unarmed uh fashion
uh i was looking for them to help
support the perimeter that was that we
had established
okay there's been some concern that i've
talked to some of the officers here and
there's obviously been some
uh conversation around this diaz as well
about the rules of engagement and about
training and authorization
uh there wasn't um training
for what to do if a mass group actually
comes through the door
and tries to burst through whether it's
an insurrection type event whether it's
just a
mob that's gone crazy and whatever maybe
or protest that gets out of hand
to be able to burst the door there was
no clarity for the officers inside the
building
on their rules of engagements once they
actually came to the building
they literally my impressions had to
make it up on their own and they
determined their stand was going to be
where the members
and the staff were located that was
going to be their stand to start using
lethal force
so i have a couple questions for that at
this point now and i understand
hindsight's 2020 is there a need for
much greater
less than lethal force capability on
officers at the time or available to
officers at a time that they have less
than lethal capabilities
and clear rules of engagement of what to
do if you have a group of individuals
come
into the building unauthorized so so
just for a little clarification we do
train for people trying to get into the
building
we don't train for when i said an
insurrection over thousands of people
right
and our officers do have less lethal
capability that they carry with them
with hindsight being what it is from
january 6th uh absolutely i think there
needs to be
additional training additional equipment
to consider this type of attack in the
future
well the challenge is we all watched
this summer in fact this committee at
homeland security
had a hearing on the assaults on a
federal courthouse
in portland and went through and all of
us saw for a month
uh individuals just attacked that
courthouse day after day after day and
we saw
the techniques that were used some of
those same techniques were used by
individuals that came here i'm not
saying it was the same individuals
but some of those same techniques are
trying to be able to work to the fence
to be able to find it to be able to find
a way to be able to attack
officers so the challenge is that we
saw that that this was rising i guess
that people were watching on tv
uh people attacking a federal
institution all summer long
and uh it is a follow-up that we're
going to have to do in the days ahead of
how to be able to get less than lethal
capability
and to find ways to be able to stop any
kind of assault
of a number of individuals to be able to
come on the capitol so i appreciate your
service
i appreciate very much the officers that
continue to be able to serve because
they've not had a gap they've not had a
break since that time period
and i know you still interact with them
at least i hope you do and uh
i would encourage you to pass on from us
our gratitude
and we're all looking at this as a
hindsight 2020 saying why couldn't you
read the tea leaves
at this particular scrap of intelligence
that came in the night before
none of us saw it at this level and uh
so we're grateful for the service they
continue to do and let's find the
lessons we can learn
thank you very much sir i know they
appreciate your support as well as the
support of congress they're
they're hell of a police agency okay
thank you senator lankford next uh thank
you for your patience senator carper
yeah my pleasure thank you madam chair
uh chief conte is a former
governor of the first state of delaware
for eight years i recall numerous
instances in
in which i uh call on the dollar
national guard
uh in emergencies they could have been
the floods blizzards ice storms
drought you name it a lot more i know
the importance of
the valley of work that our citizens
holders have done for decades in the
first
other states around the country as we
have learned in contrast to
every other state's national guard in
the country the d.c national guard
operates differently
and i'm i'm convinced if someone had
been able to activate the
dc national guard and have a thousand or
two thousand guardsmen and women
uh deployed at the capitol uh
in a timely way on the the sixth of
january
this destruction if death and
destruction would not have occurred
yeah the leader of the uh unlike the all
the states of the 50 states that we have
later
the district of columbia is not
empowered to activate the
dc national guard during an emergency
that's one of the reasons why i've
worked for years with congresswoman
eleanor holmes norton to in support of
legislation to admit to washington d.c
as our 51st state and to provide equal
rights to the americans who make this
community
over there so with 700 000 people their
home
there's questions chief copying your
testimony you highlighted a request for
d.c national guard assistance
at the u.s capitol on january 6th would
have been that
uh would have had to have been made by
the us capitol police with the consent
of the u.s department of defense
you just take a minute to explain that
process and why mayor bowser is not able
to request
dc national guard assistance when
federal installations and property as
well as human lives
uh are threatened in the district that
she leads please go ahead
yes thank you for the question yeah so
the mayor does not have
a full authority over the national guard
to include their activation or
deployment when the mayor we make a
request
as the district of columbia we make a
request we send that
to the federal government ultimately the
secretary of secretary of the army
receives that request there's a whole
approval process
that that request has to go through in
order for national guard resources to be
deployed to the district
of columbia unlike governors and other
states who are able to activate their
national guard
without going through uh those approval
processes
and receiving uh uh approval from the
highest level of the federal government
uh we just uh that that just does not
have to take place in other states so
a real hindrance to us in terms of
response and the ability to call them up
thanks thanks for that response could
you just take a minute to share with us
your thoughts on whether
having a dc national guard under the
command of a mayor or even
a governor of a neighboring state might
help the d.c metropolitan
police in coordinating with federal
authorities to better protect the city
and its citizens
and along with the federal installations
during the assault like the one we
experienced on january the 6th yes i
think we
i think we certainly uh should um
we found we know even on that day on
january the 6th
prior to any movement of the national
guard from
the assignments that they had been given
the traffic posts
again that required approval at the
highest levels of the federal government
to include the secretary
of the army and secretary of defense in
order to just move the national bar
or change the mission in essence so uh
yes i think that that should certainly
be something that falls under the
mayor's authority
all right thanks so much a question if i
could for mr sun mr sun and your
testimony you state that
the events of january 6 were not the
results of poor planning on behalf of
the u.s cabinet
but rather a lack of actionable
intelligence that
would have allowed the uh
that would have allowed the uh uh
let me start over or rather a lack of
actual intelligence that would have
allowed the us capital to leave the
capitol police to
properly prepare as i was looking
through mr stinger's testimony
former sergeant-at-arms for the u.s
senate he these things that i want to
quote he says the share of information
and resources
is paramount for success that's it
that's his quote
i strongly agree with that statement uh
mr sun
what went wrong leading up to january 6
with regard to gathering
and sharing actual intelligence why do
you think
the likelihood of a truly devastating
attack was so badly
underestimated mr sun
i think as you start to hear some from
some of the federal agencies on the
investigations that are currently going
on
where they're finding the evidence that
this was a coordinated attack
uh that had been coordinated among uh
numerous states
for some time in advance of this that's
the information that would have been
extremely helpful to us
for them to detect some type of level of
coordination that would have given us
the
indication that we're going to see more
than just a may become
violent that you know may be inclined to
violence
uh type of type of preparations you look
at it now you see
you know knowing what occurred you see
what type of resources were brought to
bear around the
around the capitol that type of
information could give us
you know sufficient advance warning to
pre plan for more of an an attack such
as what we saw
a great uh paul newman movie cool hand
luke
lying you probably a lot of people
certainly in my generation remember
what we have here is a failure to
communicate i was right at the end of
the film what we have is a failure to
communicate uh do we have a failure to
communicate here
where when i'm not one who's crazy about
like pointing fingers and
designing blind but to whom do we assign
that uh
failure to communicate
i believe that question is for me sir
what i what i look at is
you know we have a process for
communications and it being a consumer
of intelligence i look at it more of
you know we're i think there's a failure
of having a wide enough lens
to look at what are the current threats
that we're facing uh in
in in the nation uh now from some of the
domestic extremists
i think the communications processes are
there they need to be worked on a little
bit
but i think the intelligence community
needs to broaden its aperture
on what information it collects we now
know in in retrospect that the
the uh the gathering on the
the rioters on january 6th didn't begin
on january 5th the fourth or the third
it started like
weeks before and uh was fomented and
encouraged as
as we now know by by among others our
our president
and somehow that all that work and all
the intelligence was gathered
by the fbi and other homeland security
never got it found its way to
the people who right here in dc could
have used it the most to have
avoided the tragedy of january the 6th
thank you are the
our thanks to particularly the officers
of the capital ps capitol police
and others who joined them and trying to
protect us and in this capital on that
sad day
i know we have several members ready to
go and we
want you to go as quickly as possible
but there's been a request from our
witnesses who have been here a long time
if we could uh give them a five minute
break and then we will reconvene
in in five minutes with additional
questions
so we will recess for five minutes
okay
uh
sheep
you get our uh remote uh folks uh it's
good to see you on remote uh
mr sun welcome back
senator merkley you're up for questions
ah thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you to our
our witnesses uh mr sund
on january 4th mpd
arrested the leader of the proud boys
for destruction of property and
possessing high-capacity firearm
magazines
and on the following day on january 5th
the fbi issued a report through the
joint
terrorism task force which includes
going to the u.s capitol police
and that report noted that
on far uh media the threats
included things such as the comments
such as
be ready to fight congress needs to hear
glass breaking
doors being kicked in blood from their
blm and antifa
slaves soldiers being spilled get
violent stop calling this a march or a
rally or a protest
go there ready for war we get our
president or we die nothing else will
achieve
this goal did you get that fbi
intelligence
report so i addressed that right when we
started
the united states capitol police
department did get that report i was
just advised that in the last 24 hours
that report made it from the joint
terrorism task force over to our
intelligence bureau over to
a sergeant there and uh
ceased moving forward at that point uh
no leadership
myself included over at capitol police
was made aware of that at the at the
time of the event
so there is you've referred in your
testimony
uh to the individual who is the
head john donahue the director of
intelligence on the u.s
capitol police and
did did he receive that report but he
did not pass it on to
to you as head of the uscp
again i have no knowledge that he
received that report i've been told it
went over to
a official the rank of sergeant and
didn't move any further from there
um okay that's very concerning were
there not
procedures for the head of the
intelligence on the u.s capitol police
to get the intelligence report
to review it especially when there were
significant
other indications of potential violence
and and make sure that
that you as the leader had that
knowledge on which to
develop additional plans if additional
plans were needed
i'm sure that's something that they're
looking at in their current after action
yes there is a process for it
uh but again that's as i mentioned
before that was raw intelligence that
was coming in
and again taken in consideration with
everything else none of the other
intelligence was showing
that we're looking at this type of a
broad insurrectionist type of
event with thousands of armed
coordinated individuals i know you're
under you're saying that that the
folks are looking at that now but my
question
was did you have a procedure for
important intelligence to be brought
directly to your attention
and did that system break down and
that's why you did not see
the warnings about blood being spilled
get violent
call you know be ready to come and die
yes there is a process in place to make
sure that uh critical important
information is brought
uh up to the up to the leadership again
that was uh something that would have
gone through the
the development and the analysis of that
information
okay so you're saying the intelligent
side of u.s capitol police failed to get
that into your hands let me turn to
uh rules of engagement so officers are
out there and there's an expanded
perimeter which you've
you've referred to and you have those
kind of
perimeter fence that look like bike
racks uh and in a normal situation those
tell peaceful protesters this is where
you stop
was there any sort of discussion
uh or training about what to do if
protesters started picking those things
up and
opening holes in that perimeter what
were the rules of engagement if i'm a
police officer that day on the line
for the capitol police how was i
supposed was i trained like what do i do
when when those perimeter fences are
breached
do i use spray do i use a stun gun do i
use tear gas
uh what what am i do i have a clear
sense of exactly how i'm supposed to
respond
yes there is there is a rules of
engagement there's a use of force
policy and there's also civil
disobedience unit training
that has to do with when you have a
non-compliant group how you deal with
non-compliance
and gaining compliance which would
include hand control techniques
the application of chemical uh chemical
spray and then impact weapons so on that
day
you issued rules of engagement that
included what specifically i'm an
officer what was i supposed to do if
those
those barricades were breached there's
rules and engagements that exist they
weren't
issued just that day they existed they
don't vary from event to event based on
threat analysis
no sir so that perimeter
you said got larger which meant police
officers were spread out over a larger
area so once it was breached
what are the directions to the police on
the team
to be able to retreat to a defensible
point
so what we had is we had what's called
an incident command system established
you have an incident command for both
the exterior the resources on the
exterior of the building
that would provide those officers those
cdu units
with specific directions on where to go
what's the next step if you're going to
retreat up to the
upper west terrace which i believe which
is what they were told to do
as well as an instagram system inside
the building handling the joint session
and
activities going on inside so i'm out on
the the the plaza
and the crowd swarms past me i have an
assigned
place to go to retreat to that is
defensible the
incident commander would be providing
direction to people in the field
on what where to retreat to uh make the
next stance so no it no advance
in for information and how do you avoid
the situation of those who are guarding
a door
closing and locking the door and leaving
police officers stranded
outside of that locked perimeter
so your question how do you prevent that
is that you're saying how do you prevent
that
if there aren't if you've got folks who
are
guarding a door and protesters are
trying to get through it so they're
trying to lock that and prevent it
and there isn't a pre-plan for how to
deal with officers who are stranded
outside
of those doors how's that handled have
do you have drills on that do you have
set instructions on that again that's
something i would look for the
the on-site official the on-site instant
commander to provide those officers
with directions where to relocate to
okay let me put it this way
have you ever held a drill to respond to
this this situation where a crowd pushes
past
the exterior barricades not not this
level of uh situation no sir
to what level have you had such drills
we've done uh various exercises with uh
people you know um activities on the on
the grounds
during civil disobedience training how
to handle uh riotous groups
okay thank you thank you i'm gonna turn
just that seconds
left to our former sergeant of arms for
the the senate
uh mr stenger at the time that the
we were in the in the senate chamber and
the protesters the writers
uh reached the perimeter of the senate
there was a very quick rush to try to
lock the doors
and there's there were people searching
for
how do you lock these and there's many
entrances on the balcony
have there ever been any sort of a drill
with the sergeant of arms team or with
in partnership with the capitol police
on how to secure
the doors uh to the chamber as a last
point of defense uh yes sir
they at least once a year they hold a
chamber action drill
where they would work together with the
uh capitol police
uh with the doorkeepers to do a lockdown
so they know how to when when they
should lock down and when
they should do that so that is done as
an actual drill
where people have to run get the keys
lock the doors they know what
doors are supposed to guard are they
supposed to guard them from the inside
or from the outside and so forth
yes sir and when was the last such drill
of that nature conducted
i'd have to i'd have to go back and
check but try and do it once a year
okay i think i'm out of time and i thank
you very much to the chairman
thank you senator senator scott you're
recognized
thank you chairman first off i want to
thank everybody for your hard work
um the we have national guards
now she'll guard up here we've had him i
guess since around the sixth
can you all tell us how you made the
decision to
bring the national guard here each of
you to the extent you're involved or if
you're not involved
how the decision was made that's the
national guard presence
we have here now it's not as a result of
the uh the right but the national guard
has put up the fencing and
and all that okay so that was that began
to be developed
uh the evening of the sixth when we made
the request we got the national guard in
we started looking to the future what
was going to be what was going to be
next
we started talking about bringing in the
first section of global fencing
which basically went right around
capitol square which is constitutional
independence first
first we got that that in place then we
started looking at what necessary
national guard
resources working with the national
guard representative
so that was developed with um capitol
police uh working with you know i
believe sergeant arms at the time
in the evening going into the into the
seventh uh that we developed that okay
were you the only one involved or were
the sergeant arms involved
i i believe so i'd have to go back and
and pull that information we were
working on a number of different uh
aspects of it at the time
but i had my general counsel as well as
our operations people working on
the request and the coordination with
the national guard and what was the
what was the purpose of the original um
the national guard that came put up the
fencing what was the
what was the rationale what was the
threat assessment
so when just make sure i understand
you're talking about the national guard
that came on the
sixth no the net the president's at
state after
oh the one that stayed after um so what
was the the
the threat was what was the threat
assessment and why why was it set up
that they would be here for you know
it seems like now months on end well
again beyond
you know uh the eighth again you know my
departure date was the eighth so the
information i have is up until the
eighth
uh it was based they were putting them
in place based on the
mass insurrection that we had on the
sixth i wasn't aware of any additional
intelligence at that point they were
just concerned about possible
violent extremists regrouping and
staging another attack on the capital
so so you haven't you haven't seen
anything
that uh that would give us a threat
assessment now that we have a concern
that we need to have the national guard
presence it doesn't mean there's not
some but you haven't seen anything
no sir i i've been uh really um not in
that environment
since the eighth okay anybody else
that's
that's uh any of the others that are
here to testify do you have any
uh do you have any threat assessment
you've seen that there's a reason that
we have the national guard here today
is that does everybody is that a no from
everybody no one has
any any idea why we have the national
guard here
oh this is chief conte yeah uh my my
my guess is in response to all the
things that uh that have happened but to
your questions specifically about uh
specific intelligence
uh i have not personally seen uh
anything uh that suggests that
and are you involved in the decision at
all
of why the national guard's here no sir
i am not
and you they they would they've not
shared any
any threat assessment with you at all
with regard to why the national guard's
here
that has not been uh shared with me no
does that surprise you
uh i can't say that i'm i'm really uh
surprised quite frankly we have talked
about the
uh we have talked about you know
intelligence in terms of
what we expect to see in the city uh
there are several
law enforcement calls that uh that take
place between the metropolitan police
department and other
uh federal partners but again the
capital
uh police and that structure there it's
something
that you know they're not they're not um
beholden to the mayor of the district of
columbia or anything like that so
we exchanged the information that we
have but again i just have not seen
anything
specifically from them that suggest uh
defense still being
the way that it is now and i should add
also sir that
i mean obviously i think that there
needs to be a reimagining of the
security posture
uh there something certainly uh should
be there but
i'm not exactly sure the answer to that
is razor wire
and the deployment that we currently see
and the former sergeant arabs you don't
have any any reason
no one's given you any you've not seen
any information that would suggest that
we have a threat
an eminent threat that we need the
national guard here
uh i have not
and i have not either i same resign on
the seventh and have been gone since so
i have no information
okay so who would be making the decision
that the national guardian needs to be
here then and
where would the threat assessment come
from
does anybody know
and maybe look at the uh current uh
leadership
over at uh maybe the capitol police in
conjunction with the current um
sergeant arms okay so it would be the
capital head of capitol police and ex
sitting in the acting sergeant-arms that
is correct
for to give you the current information
on that and would they coordinate with
uh
the metropolitan police well if there
was uh
intelligence uh that would indicate the
need for
such activity it would usually be shared
with our partner
our local law enforcement would share
our perimeter and our borders
and if there was a threat out there
would that be
public would would there be some public
information that they would put out
normally again that all has to do with
the nature of the threat the threat the
classification level of the threat
but again that would be uh shared with
law enforcement within the district of
columbia
through through the joint uh jttf
as well as the executive award for the
jttf
i mean i'm just i'm just i'm
flabbergasted that
that not that you don't know now but
there's no public information
about why we have all this all these
national guards here i mean does that
surprise you
uh it's it's a significant uh security
deployment
again i believe it's it's based on the
the facts of what they they've seen you
know hindsight being what it is
it's the facts of what it would occurred
on january 6 this unprecedented uh
insurrection yeah thank you mr chairman
thank you uh senator senator hassan
you're recognized for your question
thank you mr chair and thanks to all of
the witnesses
for being here today i
especially want to take a moment to
acknowledge the heroism of the officers
of the u.s capitol police
law enforcement and other employees of
the capital who bravely worked to
protect our democracy on january 6
and who have done so much work to
restore our capital since that day
i also want to thank all of the families
of our law enforcement and
capitol hill staff for what they went
through watching this unfold
in real time i want to start with a
question to
chief conte if i could chief
washington dc is obviously no stranger
to large assemblies and protests
so what is the standard process
for protests in washington dc when it
comes to interagency coordination and
information sharing and following the
events of january 6
what recommendations do you have for
improving coordination and information
sharing
thank you for that question uh there are
several
discussions uh meetings that take place
between the
municipal police department as well as
our federal
partners we oftentimes uh have
coordination
calls with the national uh park service
uh simply because in a lot of the
federal lands they authorize the permits
uh for for the federal land so there's
coordination that has to happen there
between the metropolitan police
department
our u.s park police u.s capitol police
u.s secret service
uh with respect to the intelligence
again you know our partners from
the fbi they're often part of those
part of those discussions i think
that the thing kind of going forward
that certainly
needs to be looked at with respect to
specific intelligence
has been outlined throughout some of the
testimony
today when there is specific information
uh that warrants us to perhaps posture
uh differently
uh our notification system uh needs to
be uh different
uh the jttf distribution list that we
have is not something
that is a monitored list uh 24 hours a
day seven days a week that would
generate
an immediate response uh to that uh when
those
communications are sent out there are
staff members who
at some point we'll we'll get to that
information but i think
that uh as again that has been laid out
you know when we're talking about
something
uh of this magnitude that could
potentially happen and ultimately did
happen in our city
uh it should posture us to move
differently uh perhaps with
uh convening phone calls you know
immediately
and not you know counting on on an email
or something making it
through the chain to the levels that it
need to make
you know for other decisions to be made
well thank you for that answer uh
one of the things i would observe is
sometimes
ahead of events like these just
scheduling ongoing uh
check-ins uh with leadership at all of
the agencies that need to coordinate
uh can have the effect of sharing
information in real time
uh i want to move to a question uh to mr
stenger mr irving
and uh mr sund the secretary of homeland
security has the authority
to designate events with national and
international significance
as national special security events but
that didn't happen
for january 6 even given the threat
information readily available ahead of
time
designated events are eligible for
expanded federal support related to the
security of the events
so prior to january 6 did anyone from
the department of homeland security
contact you about a potential national
special security
event designation and we'll start with
you mr sund and then move to the others
uh thank you ma'am uh no i'm not aware
of anybody from uh dhs
reaching out uh and requesting you know
if we want to follow up if this wanted
to be a national special security event
uh or if we were gonna request that to
be or if they were going to
identify and designate what they call a
seer or special event rating
to the event no i'm not aware thank you
uh mr stenger mr irvin
uh no no one uh contacted me
well thank you for those answers i look
forward to following up with the
department of homeland security about
this during the next hearing on this
topic um
mr sund um my last question the officers
of the capitol police work
each and every day to keep the u.s
capitol safe and secure
we are all grateful for the brave work
of the u.s capitol police officers
on january 6. tragically the law
enforcement community
has now lost two officers to suicide
since january 6 as a result
of the insurrection and the events then
my thoughts and i'm sure the
thoughts of all of us here today are
with the families of mpd officer jeffrey
smith and u.s capitol police officer
howard liebengood mr sund what mental
health resources are currently available
to the united states capitol police
officers and
are these resources sufficient uh the
department has brought in significant
mental health resources and i certainly
do appreciate
uh your recognition of that i've talked
to a number of officers who have
definitely gone through
uh the battle and feel the that they're
feeling a lot of trauma from it
uh but i know the chief of police the
acting chief has brought in the
significant resources we had
uh the employee assistance program but
they brought in a number of outside
uh contractors uh that have very
have gotten very good response so i
think there's a lot of
mental health resources available and i
know a number of officers are taking
advantage of it which i'm happy to see
well so am i and i i would encourage
all officers who feel that they could
benefit from
counseling to to reach out for it and
i would certainly encourage and i'm sure
my colleagues here would too
that all leadership in law enforcement
uh reach out to us
if they feel the resources are strained
or
or need bolstering in some way uh thank
you all for your service thank you very
much for your testimony and for being
here today
uh to the chair and ranking members of
our respective committees
uh thank you so much for organizing this
hearing
thank you uh senator hassan uh chair now
recognizes senator hawley for his
questions
thank you mr chairman i want to begin by
saying a special thank you and a special
acknowledgement to captain mendoza
who shared her testimony earlier today
earlier this morning
captain mendoza is a native of missouri
and an alumna of park university if if
a memory serves and i just want to say
to her i want to thank her for being
here today
but also for her incredible bravery and
courage on january 6th
and on behalf of the entire state of
missouri i want to say thank you
for what you have done thank you for
what you represent and i also want to
take that opportunity to say again now
as i said on the night of that terrible
day
a thank you to all of the law
enforcement from all of our various
branches who responded in this dire
emergency
to face these criminal rioters uh these
violent criminals to repulse them from
the capital
and uh to secure this space so that the
work of congress could continue so thank
you and a special
thanks to captain mendoza from the state
of missouri
mr sunda if i could just return to to
the question about the national guard
activation i i just i'm a little bit
confused about the timeline here and i
want to ask you
that mr irving some questions just so i
can get this clear in my own head
i'm looking at your written testimony
you testified that you
spoke with mr irving at 109 actually
both of the sergeants at arms at 109
pm and i understand there's a little bit
of dispute about the timeline here
but you you do say that mr irving
advised you that he needed to run it
namely the request for the national
guard he needed to run it up the chain
of command have i got that right
that is correct sir okay mr irving could
i just ask you
when mr sun says that you told him you
needed to run it up the chain of command
to whom were you referring there
senator i do not recall
a phone call at 109 when i was on the
floor
of the house during the electoral
college session
my phone records do not reflect a
telephone call
at that time and had i received a call
at that time i had everyone with me
i had mr stanger leadership we would
have approved it immediately
so i i i have no recollection of that
call
and neither do i have a a record of it
you
you say i think that you spoke uh with
mr sun
later at approximately 1 30 is that
right
that is correct after i left the floor
and on that call
he had indicated to me that
conditions were deteriorating and that
he might be making a request
at a later time okay and you did you
then say that you needed to run it up
the chain of command or words to that
effect
no not to my recollection i notified
leadership and i went to michael
stenger's office
to receive updates from mr sund as to
conditions outside
and to determine whether he needed to
make a request or not
and when the request was made shortly
after two
we approved it and when you say we who's
we
we approved it i was in uh michael
stinger's office so
next to uh mr stanger and so you did not
consult congressional leadership
you weren't waiting at any point for
input from congressional leadership is
is that
your testimony mr irving i've got that
right yes i i advise them
as we would do with many security
protocols
but you weren't waiting for them at at
any point
there was no delay you're saying in
getting national guard requests because
you didn't at any point actually
wait for the input of the speaker or the
majority leader or
anybody else no absolutely not mr sund
is is that your recollection
my recollection was at 109 while i was
sitting in the command center watching
things rapidly deteriorate
i made a a phone call the phone call was
made in the presence of i believe both
my assistant chiefs
and possibly my my general counsel at
which time i made the initial request
uh that we need to activate the national
guard
uh the situation is bad on the west
front uh i followed up at 122
to check on the status of the request
okay one of the things i'm trying to to
get clear on here is who would
constitute the chain of command now it
sounds like mr irving is saying that
that he actually never made that
statement and he didn't consult anybody
else i mean my understanding is from the
statute
to usc chapter 29 section 1970
that in an emergency situation i would
think that this would qualify
that the capitol police board does not
have to consult with members of the
senator house leadership
in order to make a request for
deployment of the national guard or
request of other executive departments
and executive
agencies so it would seem strange to me
that there was any talk about a
chain of command that would evolve
anybody other than the capitol police
board given
the statute but it seems there seems to
be some confusion about
about the basic facts and and who asked
for what when
um let me just ask you this mr sun on
monday january the 4th
you've testified that you approached the
house and senate sergeant-at-arms to
request the assistance
of the national guard and mr irving
stated that he was concerned about the
optics of having the guard deployed is
that right am i remembering that
correctly
that is correct sir on the on the fourth
it actually um wasn't a phone call it
was an
in-person visit over to his office uh
where i went and requested
the national guard and mr irving could
you just clarify when you when you use
the
the term optics or and maybe your
recollection is you didn't so maybe you
could speak to that did you talk about
being concerned about the optics of the
national guard and then
could you just elaborate on what you
meant by that again this is monday
january the 4th
now yeah on monday january the 4th
senator
safety was always the deciding factor
making security plans and the issue the
issue on the table was whether the
intelligence
warranted troops at the capitol and
the conversation with mr sun was
not i did not take it as a request he
was merely informing me
that he had received an offer from the
national guard and then when we included
mr stanger
the three of us discussed the specific
issue as to whether
the intelligence warranted the troops
and the answer was no it was a
collective answer no and then mr stenger
put forth
uh his recommendation to have them on
standby and my recollection was mr sun
was very satisfied with that in fact he
briefed
the following day that he was satisfied
and i heard no
uh concern any time thereafter
were you concerned this use of the word
optics the appearance what it would look
like to have the guard this is what mr
sundis testified was a concern on
january 4th that there was reluctance
to to request assistance because of the
appearance
was there something that you were what's
the appearance that you were concerned
about mr irving if if indeed you were
were you concerned that
having the guard present would would
look like it was too militarized were
you concerned about the criticism of the
guard
being deployed in washington during
rioting earlier
this summer the summer of 2020 would
just just give us some insight into your
your thinking there as you recall it
senator i was not concerned
about appearance whatsoever it was all
about safety and security
the the any reference
would have been related to appropriate
use of force
display of force and ultimately the
question on the table
when we look to any security asset is
does the intelligence
warrant it is the security plan matched
with the intelligence
and again the collective answer was yes
mr chairman can i just ask one one final
uh question
thank you madam chair thank you um
speaker pelosi has asked retired
lieutenant general russell honore to
lead an immediate review of capital
security in light of the attack
the general has said that the leadership
of the capitol police would be you mr
sund and both of you gentlemen the house
and senate sergeants at arms
he's criticized you for and i'm quoting
now the appearance of complicity
during the attack and also said that you
were potentially
undertook complicit actions those are
his words during the attack
mr sund were you complicit in this
attack on january 6th
absolutely not sir i've heard those
comments as well i think it's
disrespectful to myself and to the
members of the
capitol police department mr stinger
were you complicit in the attacks on
january 6th
mr singer
were you complicit in the attacks on
january 6th
mr irving were you complicit in the
attacks on january 6th
absolutely not senator yeah i i think of
course
none of you were there's absolutely no
evidence to that effect and mr sun i
think your comments are appropriately
taken to allege that you
any of you were complicit
in this violent mob attack on this
building
i think is not only extremely
disrespectful uh it's it's really quite
shocking and this person has no business
leading any security review
related to the events of january 6.
thank you for your indulgence madam
chair
uh thank you very much uh next a member
a new member of both uh committees
uh senator padilla thank you madam chair
um there's been a lot of questions i've
been popping in and out from
multiple committees but i understand
there's a lot of questions already about
intelligence what was known uh supposed
assessed what was shared
etc and differing opinions i'll try not
to be too repetitive
first a quick question for chief son and
the two
sergeant-at-arms i imagine
like most people you saw most if not
all of the house impeachment manager's
presentations before the united states
senate uh
as they sort of laid out the case set
the impeachment question aside
we know how that was resolved but
in terms of how january 6 didn't just
happen but the lead-up to january 6th
is there anything from that presentation
uh that you would disagree with
so to just make sure i understand the
video i watched and all the information
the
the video that was portrayed is all
accurate
uh video as far as the you know any of
the other uh commentary associated with
the video
i can't say i watched every single bit
of it uh but i can tell you the video
a lot of that video was video from the
united states capitol police
it was all accurate okay thank you mr
stanger mr irving
same question uh yeah uh the video i saw
certainly reflected what i could see
from my window on the day
of january 6.
and from my perspective senator i
have not diagnosed the why the attack
occurred
at the time we left all information
um to the intelligence agencies that we
had at the time and i would say now
to leave it to the after action
investigations to make determinations
okay uh question for uh chieftain
specifically
now there is a an intelligence division
within the department correct yes sir
okay uh and
now having read your letter to speaker
pelosi you make reference to
events on both november 14th as well as
december 12th
that you had sort of comparable
intelligence in terms of risk assessment
threat assessment uh in the event of
november
14th and december 12th not leading into
anything near
what uh happened on january 6th
is that my correct interpretation of
your letter yes that is the correct
interpretation
of the letter both the assessments
indicated that we were going to have
various militia groups um and extremists
in attendance
in addition to the fact that as uh chief
conte had
testified to earlier uh weapons were
recovered uh during both those events
okay and so uh to the best of your
recollection
in the lead up to january 6th since it
was comparable assessment comparable
intelligence
roughly uh you therefore proceeded with
comparable
preparation and posture yeah that is
that is absolutely correct we
proceeded with the posture of seeing it
could have uh
instances of violence we knew it was
going to be focused on the capital
we knew that there was going to be
members of proud boy antifa
uh participating and like i'd said
before not capitol police not
metropolitan police not any of our
federal agencies had any information
we're going to be facing armed
insurrection of thousands of people now
if we take uh
our experience with uh terrorism
globally uh and look at case studies
uh both incidents that were have been
prevented and those that were
successfully
executed against the united states
is it plausible and i know hindsight's
2020 is it plausible that
the november 14th december 12th
incidents may well have been
trial runs the very
extremist organizations you've
referenced
involved with the organizing and
participation of
november 14th december 12th
to gain counter intelligence on how you
and your partner agencies
would be planning and preparing
for such incidents well as you rightly
point out when you look at some of the
uh
terrorist attacks that have occurred
there has been
pre-planning there has been
pre-surveillance uh pre-collection of
intelligence on the security features
i don't know if the november and
december were two instances of that but
i would suspect
with the fact that we're finding this
was a coordinated attack i wouldn't
doubt there was
um pre-surveillance so we know they were
we don't know they weren't
that's my correct correct and i know the
intelligence folks will be here at a
subsequent hearing but we're all in this
together in your letter and your
testimony earlier today you uh bluntly
said the intelligence community
missed this that is correct sir that's
the way i feel
now who was commander-in-chief on
december 6.
when you say commander-in-chief who is
the president of the united states
uh donald trump sir overseeing the
intelligence community that missed this
repeat your answer for the the entire 18
agencies that represent the intelligence
community
yes sir they would be commander in chief
and who is that again
president donald trump okay
let me ask a couple questions on a
different topic
i think it's obvious to many across the
country i was one of three senators who
was not in chambers
on january 6 i had you know the benefit
if you will
of watching the events occur in real
time both inside the capitol and outside
the capitol on television
one thing that was not lost on me and
many people that i've talked to
is the difference in both police
presence and response
on january 6 compared to
events from last summer when peaceful
protesters
were demonstrating in the nation's
capital in the wake of george soy's
murder last summer they were met with
significant force a couple of data
points
to date some 250 individuals who were
involved in the capital insurrection of
january 6
have been arrested more will likely be
arrested in the coming weeks and months
but only a small number about 52
of these individuals were arrested on
january 6th
by contrast during the largely peaceful
protest
of last summer 427 people
were arrested on january excuse me on
june 1st
alone 289 people were arrested
similarly some 300 protesters were
arrested during
the kavanaugh hearings in 2018.
so question mr sun
how can you tell us exactly how the
capitol police preparations for january
6 differed from preparations
for the protests from last summer
and if you can specifically address if
they were the same or
different use of ford guidelines in
place on january 6th
compared to the protests of last summer
or any criteria for making
arrests on january 6th versus the
protest
from last summer okay and if you could
do that in about a minute uh
yes ma'am i will thank you i will do
that very concisely okay
so i want to look at it from planning
and preparations we plan for every
demonstration
the exact same way doesn't matter the
the message of the
the person doesn't matter the
demographics of the grievance involved
in the demonstration
we do it the exact same way we develop
our information we develop our intel and
we base a response plan on that
so let's transition to preparations i
will tell you we handled
15 major demonstrations
involving black lives matter's groups
you know following the the death of
george florida over the summer
we had a total of six arrests six
arrests
no use of less lethal capabilities no
use of lethal force capabilities
the uh events the everything that we put
into place for january 6
far exceeded any planning that we did
for any events in 20 in in 2020
with the full activation of the
department the size of the perimeter
that we expanded
the deployment of additional protective
equipment the deployment of
less lethal and the application of less
lethal
with far exceeded anything any other
event that i can recollect on the
nation's capital
uh so i'll just leave it at that we
thank you and prepared much more
thank you we're going to go and thank
you senator padilla we're going to go to
senator hagerty and then to senator king
who's been very patient and been on with
us online
at quite a while senator haggarty thank
you chairman klobuchar
um thank you very much for for uh having
us here today and holding this hearing
i want to begin by thanking all the law
enforcement officers that are
represented here today
you and your families thank you for your
sacrifice and certainly my heart was out
to those
families and their loved ones who lost
their lives in this
in the spring of uh spring and summer of
2020 many people criticized the use of
the national guard
to help restore order in washington
following some of the worst rioting in
decades
mayor bowser said that the guard
presence was and i quote unnecessary and
may be counterproductive
and a dc national guard leader even had
to tell his troops a quote again
some of the d.c public does not agree
with our mission and may have nefarious
intention toward our servicemen
and according to a january 5th
washington post report top
pentagon officials emphasized that on
january 6
the guard would have a quote far more
muted presence
than in june saying that quote we've
learned our lessons
will be absolutely nowhere near the
capitol building
mr sunday stated that despite attempting
to attain national guard support on
capitol hill on january 6 he was unable
to get approval
such support and several people today
have referred to concerns over the
optics
of january the 6th so my first question
is directed to mr sun
do you think that the backlash against
the use of national guard troops to
restore order back in
summer time led to reluctance in advance
of january 6 to utilize guard troops to
protect the capital
uh sir i cannot really testify to what
the inner workings was or working
decisions
over at the pentagon regarding either
the decisions from the over the summer
or the memo that was put out by the
secretary of the army on the 4th
however i was very surprised at the
amount of time and the pushback i was
receiving
when i was making an urgent request for
their assistance
that's regrettable uh i'd also like to
uh follow up on a line of questioning
that senator hawley brought up
uh speaker pelosi indicated that she
intends to establish a commission
to examine the events of january 6. of
course that's why we're here today
examining those issues speaker pelosi
has also appointed
a retired army lieutenant general
russell honore who is going to lead the
investigation what happened
but days after the attack general
honoree said i think
once all this gets uncovered again i'm
quoting him
it was complicit actions by capitol
police
before he added that you mr sund were
quote complicit along with the
sergeant-at-arms
in the house and senate my question is
do any of you believe that comments like
these by mr honorek
suggest that he is someone who is well
suited to conduct a serious
and unbiased review of the events of
january 6. if so
please explain i'll go ahead and
start with that response as i mentioned
before
i found the the comments that he made
regarding myself
and also the capitol police officers
highly disrespectful to the hard-working
women and men
of that police department and also to
myself uh i welcome and i look forward
to
an after-action that will move this
agency forward move our partnership with
the federal agencies forward
but it has to be done in an unbiased
fashion
i couldn't agree more mr sun
any other responses
i i would disagree with the generals uh
what he said
i don't believe that's true there's a
lot of people that put themselves in
very much danger on that day and
uh i think so saying something like that
is just
not good taste
yeah i i i can't imagine uh that being
said myself
implying that you all were complicit in
this but i thank you
for for your answer for your service
i yield back sure madam chairman uh
thank you very much senator hegarty uh
next center king
um you may be muted senator king oh i
got it okay great
thank you madam chair and i i want to
thank the witnesses uh
first for their uh patients this morning
and their thorough going answers this
has been a long hearing and
and uh i really appreciate it i
appreciate the fact that
uh although you all are no longer other
than
the chief in washington no longer in
your positions
you've come forward to to give us the
benefit of your observations
it seems to me one of the clear and
there's no i'm not going to plow this
ground again but one of the clear
uh uh pieces of information we've
learned today
is a is an intelligence failure not
necessarily a failure of intelligence
but a failure to communicate
intelligence
and uh i think that's something uh that
we all need to
to think about and you can be very
helpful to us in
uh in in suggesting what should be the
the chain of communication in terms of
of the
of intelligence you can't adequately
prepare if you don't have the
information
uh and it clearly uh seems to me there
were some failures
uh chief sunda i have a a
a specific question for you and it's
more forward-looking and i
but i'd appreciate your insights the
question is
how do we protect the capital from
either of
an angry mob or probably more likely
uh one or two or three uh
malignant uh actors
without turning it into a fortress how
do we allow the american people to
go in the rotunda to tour the capitol to
picnic on the grounds to uh
play with their uh kids uh
that it seems to me that going forward
that's really one of the challenges
we want security but we don't i i would
hate to see the us capital turned into a
fortress
your thoughts mr sun
i think you need your mic on there thank
you
there you go ma'am thank you very much
i'll go back to your original comment
with the
with the intelligence and the in the
communications
i think we have the process in place for
when we have credible intelligence
especially high-level credible
intelligence
to quickly get to where it needs to be i
think my big concern
is you know on the on the collection on
how wide we're casting the net to
collect uh to collect our intelligence
that would have revealed
this was coming uh and we were facing
this type of mass insurrection
uh i definitely want to say the capitol
police is well versed well trained
on handling what you're talking about a
mumbai style attack
uh a couple of uh you know um attackers
armed
um active shooter events things like
that those are the type of events that
we are ready for
it is the thousands of people that are
storming the capital that creates a big
issue with us
so when you talk about you know physical
security and i mentioned
in one in my opening statement and one
of the initial questions
i think there are options for
maintaining
a an open environment an open campus
type of environment
while putting some substantial uh
physical security uh measures in place
both
for the building the skin of the
building as well as uh farther out you
know time and distance is our best
friend
uh and the most important thing is to
you know provide some kind of protection
farther out so the officers have more
you know more time to deal with it but
that's something that i think should be
discussed uh in a closed or classified
session
i i i understand but uh and i hope that
that is a discussion madam chair that we
can have i think that's a a very
important
uh because we we just as i say we don't
want the united states capital to be
uh so protected that it's inaccessible
to the american people
um amplify on your on your intelligence
it seems some
intelligence answer it seems to be
you're saying we
it's communicated adequately but we
didn't have the
collection that we needed for example
the norfolk virginia
letter uh is it
how do how does it get filtered and
where does it get filtered
again the the north norfolk uh the
norfolk field office letter
that's something that something
considered because even the on the 5th
at noon on the 5th i held a joint
conference call with the members of the
board
my executive team a dozen of the top law
enforcement and military officials from
washington d.c
where we discussed the upcoming events
on the 6th the upcoming events on the
for the inauguration any kind of threats
any kind of issues we may have
and even though i had you know we had
the director of the field office the
uh for the washington field office of
the fbi nothing was mentioned about it
uh so i think my big uh big point is
i think we need to look out there's
significant evidence coming out
that the insurrection that occurred on
the sixth was planned
coordinated well in advance coordinated
almost the point where you're looking
between number of states
where you're you're having events
coordinated and it's that detection that
i think would have been key
to putting the uh effective security in
place with it for this event
finally when we're when we're talking
about uh providing this
this level of security do you
is there a playbook is there a uh uh
a a contingency plan that's literally
sitting on a shelf somewhere that says
of demonstrations around the capitol
here's what you do
it i mean some of the timing things for
example the deployment of the national
guard
might have been faster had there been a
pre-determined
uh set of phone numbers actions
steps to be taken does that exist and if
not should it exist
to the level where you're including the
national guard there's a process where
we handle
special events and demonstrations uh but
i i tend to agree that we need to
streamline
the process that we request the national
guard in the future
and and yeah because clearly there was a
important there was a delay there that
was an important part of the
important part of the the response at
the time uh
madam chair again i want to thank these
witnesses i think they've really made a
contribution
uh and uh they made a contribution when
they were
serving in their respective positions
thank you i yield back
thank you thank you senator uh senator
simmons cinema is
recognized for her questions oh thank
you mr chairman
um my first question is for chief conte
what
coordinating actions were taken in the
weeks leading up to january 6
to share intel across federal and local
law enforcement
and what security planning took place
and with which
agencies thank you for that question
so there were a series of several
meetings
that took place leading up to
the events of january the 6th the weekly
law enforcement partners calls that take
place where our federal partners are
part of that
there's the first amendment coordinating
calls that took place
at least two of those prior to this
event there's a national
park service permit call that also took
place
uh prior to this event and as chief sun
mentioned uh several uh involving
several of the law enforcement entities
leading up to the events of january
of the 6th so there are significant
amount of
phone calls or virtual meetings
that took place leading up to january 6.
uh thank you and could you talk a little
bit about what you see
as the mistakes that were made or the
holes
um that didn't help connect all those
dots in those meetings and coordinating
prior to january 6.
so i i think the the major uh issue at
least from my
uh perspective i think that
in terms of the the sharing
of information how it's shared i think
that that uh
that is where the focus uh should be
again
we're talking about uh a report that
came from the norfolk office
uh on the day before the night that
night
it's around after seven o'clock p.m that
was sent
to email boxes you know as the chief of
police for the metropolitan police
department
i assure you that my phone is on 24
hours a day
seven days a week and i'm available for
any phone call
from any agency that has information
with respect to
something of this magnitude are
happening in our city
uh certainly if there was uh information
about
one of our police stations being overrun
or a federal building
being overrun that was related to the
metropolitan police department
i assure you that i would be on the
phone directly with
the uh officials that are responsible
for the law enforcement response
uh to give them that information
firsthand
i'm not really relying on technology in
the form of an email
in hopes that that information makes it
to where it needs to uh where it needs
to be
so i think that that's critical uh to
chief sun's point
uh there were several phone calls
leading up to this and no specific
information that
talked about on the events that we saw
and experienced on january the 6th and i
really do believe uh that there should
be
quite a bit of attention given to that i
appreciate that
my next question is from mr suns so you
outlined that the fbi report was sent
via email
to the capitol police the evening of
january 5th and that you never received
to the report
um is there an understanding within the
system
of how that report did not make it to
you or to
uh other individuals in leadership
in the capitol police the night of
january the 5th
i appreciate that question ma'am
actually as i mentioned earlier
in the discussion this is a report that
i am just learning about within the last
you know the informing yesterday of the
report so i'm not sure what
uh investigation may be going on i've
since
since january 8th i have left the
department uh what investigations i
know the chief has put additional safe
safeguards in place to make sure
something like that doesn't happen again
but i'm not sure what the outcome of was
why that didn't get pushed farther
was there an expectation or a process or
procedure prior to january 6
that should have gotten that memo up to
your attention
the night of january 5th there's there's
a process that ensures that
information uh from the joint terrorism
task force and through our task force
officers
gets over to their intelligence division
and would be
moved up to our uh agents analysts and
the director of that intelligence
division
and then based on that information he
could push it then up to the assistant
chief or directly to me he has my cell
phone number
uh we talk regularly and so
to you and as you mentioned you were
just learning about this recently but
would it have been an expectation that
the fbi would have called capitol police
or someone
on the joint task force to alert the new
intelligence
in in an expedited fashion knowing that
this information
made it to the capitol police intel team
on the 5th
what i'm trying to understand is how it
did not get
to the higher levels to make
preparations the night of the fifth
right let me i'll just go ahead and echo
what chief conte had mentioned
that i do think that deserves additional
focus i think if we have information
that's coming
in the day before a major event uh that
that has that level of specificity
that it could get a little more
attention than you know just being
handled either through an email or
electronic uh
format was there any intelligence that
you
did receive in the several days leading
up to january 6
that caused you to change any of the
security plans
amongst the united states capitol police
so yeah just to just reiterate you know
all the intelligence and all the
information that we've been receiving
during the development this um the event
for the sixth
outlined very similar to what the
intelligence report that we that was
published on the third
uh outline we were expecting large
number of protesters coming in
we expected a potentially violent uh
group we knew they were being focused on
the capital
and we knew that someone had a uh may be
armed
and is that is what was really driving
up until even you know regardless of
what was put out the third
this was information that we we knew we
were developing our security plan
around that and that's when we looked at
you know we
uh based on our review of the november
and december
mega events determined we were going to
adjust our fence line and push our fence
line out
and when we wanted to do that that's
when i requested the national guard
knowing we're going to need support for
the fence line
thank you you know chief conte you
stated that the intelligence that you
had received on january 6
didn't differ from the previous maga
marches the two previous
was there any conversation or
consideration
about the fact that the january 6 was
scheduled
on a very important day that congress
would be in session
certifying the results of the election
and was that
different in a consideration around
security
um than the other two marches which had
been on weekends without congress being
in session
absolutely and that's reflected in the
response posture for the metropolitan
police department
for the two prior demonstrations that
happened
the maga one and two marches the
metropolitan police department
we did not call up officers from
surrounding jurisdictions to be
stationed physically
within the footprint of the district of
columbia we did not do that before
uh the mayor in addition to uh calling
up those additional resources
again called up the national guard
specifically uh for the reasons that we
outline to them
also to which would allow the
metropolitan police department
to be a lot nimble in our response that
in us
in essence enabled us to be to be able
to respond
quickly to assist the capitol police
officers so those response
those responses were different we were
disrupting
individuals or intercepting individuals
who were armed
with firearms in our city in violation
of the mayor's order many
of whom that were on pump on our
federal federal grounds so the
metropolitan police department's
uh posture certainly was escalated
beyond what we did
the prior two marches thank you mr
chairman i appreciate your indulgence i
see i've gone over my time i have a few
extra questions that i'll submit
thank you okay very good thank you
senator cinema
and thank you for your emphasis on the
fbi report and the issues that i
everyone here seems to acknowledge with
uh getting
uh that that it didn't go at the right
place and just putting
send isn't enough for a report like that
okay uh next we have senator cruz and
then after that
will be senator ossoff and if there's
any other senators who wish to ask
questions who haven't asked questions
uh you should tell us because those are
the last two we have senator cruz
thank you madam chair and let me say to
each of the witnesses
here today thank you for being here
thank you for your testimony
and and thank you also for your service
i want to thank each of you
and and also each of the heroic law
enforcement officers who who
demonstrated
extraordinary courage in
fighting to repel the terrorist attack
that unfolded
on the capitol on january 6th and and we
are grateful
for the bravery and the courage in the
in the face of a truly horrific attack
in the aftermath of that attack there is
naturally a process
uh to assess
what could have been done to better
prevent that attack to better secure the
capital
and i think everyone recognizes that
that
hindsight is different from a decision
made
in the moment facing the threat
immediately but this this hearing is
nonetheless
productive for analyzing the security
decisions and law enforcement decisions
that were made real time
and for learning from them what can be
done differently to ensure that that an
attack like that
never again occurs chief sander
i i want to focus on with some detail
your your
written testimony and just walk through
what what occurred
in the days preceding january 6th and
then on january 6. so in your written
testimony
you say on monday january 4th i
approached the two sergeant-at-arms to
request the assistance of the national
guard as you had no authority to do so
you go on to say i first spoke with the
house sergeant at arms to request the
national guard
mr irving stated that he was concerned
about the quote optics of having
national guard present
and didn't feel the intelligence
supported it
he referred me to the senate
sergeant-at-arms to get his thoughts on
the request i then spoke to mr stenger
and again
requested the national guard instead of
approving the use of the national guard
however mr stenger suggested i
asked then how quickly we could get
support if needed
and to lean forward in case we had to
request assistance
on on january 6. can you describe
at a little more length those
conversations with with the two
sergeant-at-arms on on january 4th
absolutely sir the first conversation
occurred
monday morning i went over i have to
refer to my notes but sometime maybe
around 11 o'clock in the morning
i saw it met with mr irving in his
office that's where i made the first
request for the
for the national guard uh he had
indicated i don't i don't know if i
really like the optics
you know i don't think the intelligence
really really supports it he had like we
had said
recommended i talked to the senate
sergeant arms i went over and met with
uh later on the day
either i'm trying to recall if he's in
person or over the phone i have to go
back to my
my record at my timeline where i reached
out to him
and they may have already talked because
he had referred me he said do you
know somebody over at the dc national
guard i said yes i do have a good friend
over there general william walker
he said can you give him a call and see
if we needed assistance
how quickly could we get assistance and
what type of assistance could he give us
so that evening as i was driving home at
about 6 35 at night
i went ahead and called general walker
and and spoke to him and said hey
general walker i don't have
authority to request national guard but
i want to find out if we needed them on
wednesday
how quickly could you get them for us
and is there a way you can kind of you
know be prepared just in case we put in
the
put in the request at that point he had
advised me
that he has 125 national guardsmen who
are supporting
the coveted response in the district of
columbia and if we needed a
response a quick response he could what
he called repurpose them
and get them to the armory at which
point we could get somebody over to
swear them in and try and get them to us
as quick as possible
we ended our call uh the next day i met
with uh both
uh miss i met with mr um stinger he came
over to the office for the 12 o'clock
video call that i had hosted with the
dozen of the law enforcement
officials from the national capital for
the from dc
we spoke about it briefly there and uh
told him what
william walker had told me as well as i
passed on to mr irving i think later on
that afternoon they both seemed
satisfied with that response
so mr irving and mr stenger mr irving
as i understand it you have some
disagreement with the characterization
uh about the concern about the optics so
so i would
invite both mr irving and mr stenger to
to
relay your best recollection of that
conversation on january 4th
senator my best recollection of the
conversation
on january 4th was a phone call from
chief sund
indicating that he had received an offer
for 125 unarmed
guard that could be positioned around
traffic perimeter checkpoints at the
capitol
my recollection again is as we followed
up with mr stenger the three of us
engaged in a conversation whereby we
looked at the
offer in light of the existing
intelligence
and the decision the collect decision
amongst the three of us was
that the intelligence did not warrant
the
national guard and my recollection that
ended
the discussion relative to the the offer
and the only question on the table is
any should we do
perform any follow-up and mr stenger
recommended
that we ask that we that they be placed
on standby
and that was the end question so to to
the best of your recollection did you
make
the comment about optics and and if so
what
what did you mean by that i cannot
remember my exact verbiage
had i used any language to the effect
i it was all in reference to
whether the intelligence was matched to
the security plan
and and let me ask both mr irving and mr
stenger did did you all have
conversations with congressional
leadership
either democratic or republican
leadership on this question
of supplementing law enforcement
presence bringing in national guard
either on january 4th or real time in
january 6.
on january 4th no i had no follow-up
conversations
and it was not until the 6th that i
alerted leadership that
we might be making a request
and that was the end of the discussion
mr sanger
for myself it was january 6 that i
mentioned it to
uh leader mcdonald's dad
there's been some disagreement about
what time phone calls occurred i know
senator portman asked
earlier presumably everyone has phone
records i think it would be helpful
if if each of you could forward the
relevant phone records to this committee
and and chief sanju also referenced in
your testimony
that you sent an email to
congressional leadership
[Music]
if you could forward that to the
committee as well i think that would be
helpful
thank you
thank you senator assaf
thank you madam chair thank you to our
panel just want to take a moment and
echo
the sentiments of so many of my
colleagues expressing appreciation for
the men and women of the united states
capitol police
who endured a great deal on january 6th
and showed
great heroism and also madam chair if i
might express
an interest in working with you to
ensure that they're well taken care of
and their needs are met
this discussion of the conversation that
the three of you had
regarding supplementary security support
on
suggestion who's in
is consensus between the two sergeants
at arms and the chief of the u.s capitol
police required to make such a request
mr sund the rules for the national guard
needs to go to the capitol police board
for approval yes
who has ultimate responsibility
for the security of the u.s capitol
complex which individual
i believe that falls under the capitol
police board the capitol police board so
there is no individual
who has personal responsibility for the
security of the u.s capitol complex
that's where i interpret it yes
had the u.s capitol police conducted
exercises
simulating comparable events such as a
violent riot
on or within the u.s capital complex
part of our part of our training for
civil disobedience units
involves dealing with riotous groups so
we do do that training
we do do training on people attempting
to gain entry into the
into the building uh officers are
trained on how to handle if someone
tries to
come through your door uh unauthorized
uh but
training for thousands of you know armed
insurrectionists they were
coordinated and well equipped uh no we
have not had that training before
january 6th
but i'm sure we'll find a way to uh i'm
sure they'll find a way to do it now
so if i understand correctly mr sund
you're saying that
personnel had engaged in tactical
training regarding techniques to repel
attempts to breach the complex regarding
rules of engagement
but had any comprehensive exercises
that included command that included
procedures for coordination with
supporting agencies that included
requests for support that included
communications with the department of
defense or white house officials or
guard units been conducted
yes we have we we do exercises that are
very similar to what what you're talking
about
before some of our national special
security events
uh those are the nsses such as the
inauguration we'll do
uh tabletop exercises that go through
the
the process of what you're talking about
yes thank you and and
had the capitol police held any such
exercises
not pertaining to specific national
security special events
so in order to deal with emergent
contingencies like a riot uh not
associated with one of those moments
specifically identified as requiring a
whole of government security response
yeah one of one of the most important
aspects of that you're talking about
that we
um we train our individuals to is what
we call the incident command system
that's one of the one of the systems
that we we feel really under the
um unprecedented pressure that they
exhibited on january 6
begin to break down the incident command
system is established specifically so
you have
people that have the clearest
understanding of what's happening either
in the field or inside the building
in control of the resources to utilize
to defend against whatever issue you're
having or respond to whatever incident
you have
it's really an all-hazards approach but
that is something that's trained
we have it as part of our general orders
uh that is something that we'll need to
look back on to see how it
broke under this pressure and i asked
this question in part because of the
account that's been shared
regarding the coordination with the
guard unit
which was here for covid related mission
and
if i recall correctly you related you
had a conversation with the commanding
officer and discussed
uh mobilizing that unit if necessary
first via an intermediary stop at a
marine corps facility to then
come to the capitol if necessary on
january 6 were there not pre-existing
channels of communication and procedures
in the event you not
at a moment such as inauguration over
state of the union but on any given day
needed a quick reaction force to provide
security support
well i think when you refer to it i
think it's the established process where
if you're going to request them in
advance or request them for
an incident i think we need to look at
is those emergency requests
but there is a process for going through
the secretary of the army placing an
official request
ultimately we did that we we had to do a
letterhead after the fact
we did the oral request first uh and set
it up that way
but i think what i did by reaching out
to general walker was to get an idea
much like as i was requested to do if we
requested them on the 6th
what kind of resources could they give
us and what type of time frame would we
be looking at but i agree there's
already existing process and channels
for making the request for national
guard right because you in fact
anticipated there might be some need
based upon intelligence that your
department was seeing but on any given
day if a foreign terrorist
place such that a organizat reaction
force can be mustered swiftly
such that someone in your position knows
exactly who to call and they can do so
without consulting with the sergeants at
arms
i think what you're seeing is what we
need to look at because i'd still be
required to consult with the sergeant
arms to make the request for national
guard
okay my time is running short so i want
to ask you this what is the intelligence
budget
for the u.s capitol police and how many
personnel do you have
in the intelligence division or did you
have when you served as the chief
i'd have to go back and pull that
specific information uh we have a number
of uh
intel analysts we have a number of
people that work there but sworn and
civilian
but i want to give you clear and action
approximately how many personnel are in
the intelligence division i'd say
approximately right around 30 35
people 30 or 35. and does the u.s
capitol police
have the capacity to do any intelligence
collection
other than by making requests to
executive branch agencies for raw
intelligence or analysis
again when you talk uh about
intelligence collection we're a consumer
of intelligence from the intelligence um
uh uh committee uh community i'm sorry
um we do have the ability to go and look
at like open source see what's
what people are talking about on open
source but going and collecting um
in-depth specific uh intelligence is
something that we're a consumer of from
the intelligence community
thank you appreciate your time
ambassador
well thank you very much uh that was our
last
set of questions and we're going to
conclude this hearing i wanted to say
a few words at the end first of all i
want to thank
chairman peters and senators ranking
members blunt and portman
for conducting this hearing in such a
professional way
we had a bipartisan agreement on how
this hearing would be conducted
who our witnesses would be and
also the plan to have additional
hearings including one next week that
we'll be announcing tomorrow with the
department of defense department of
homeland security and the fbi
because clearly we have and our members
have additional questions
i want to thank the witnesses as i said
for voluntarily appearing
uh before us i want to thank captain
mendoza for her
moving words and bravery in many ways
she represents
all of the officers that were there that
day
a few things that are very clear to me
the first
is the statements at the beginning
from all the witnesses they may have
disagreed on some details
and you know okay but there is clear
agreement
that this was a planned insurrection so
and i think most members here
um uh very firmly agree with that
um and i think it's important for the
public to know that this was planned
we now know this was a planned
insurrection it involved
a white supremacist it involved
extremist groups
and it certainly could have been so much
worse except for the bravery of
the officers uh we learned about the
intelligence breakdown so many of the
members of both
committees asked about that uh
particularly the
january 5th the fbi report
that had some very significant warnings
from social media about people who were
coming to washington who wanted to wage
war the fact that did not get to key
leaders
in the sergeant of arms or the capitol
police chief is of course very
disturbing
really on both ends i mean you can't
just push send as we all know we get
tons of emails
and hope that it gets to the right
person
especially when we're dealing with
something so serious the january
third intelligence report that was came
right out of the capitol police also
contained according to washington post
reports
and other information some pretty
foreboding
details that i would have thought would
have resulted
in planning and more preparations the
delays
in the proving a request for national
guard assistance both from the
capitol police board and the department
of defense
uh the fact that the sergeant-at-arms
were focused on keeping the members safe
in both chambers uh while the chief was
trying to get some emergency approval to
me
you can point fingers but you could also
look at this
as a process that is not prepared
for a crisis and i think out of that
there's some general agreement
just based on talking to a number of
members
that there should be changes to the
capitol police
board uh the approval process and the
like and it's clear that that action
must be taken not only to
protect our capital but also
to protect the brave officers charged
with protecting
the citadel of democracy
better intelligence sharing always an
outcome when there's
failures of intelligence we know that
but i think we'll get more details
in the coming week some security changes
at the capitol
requests that have been made for a while
on those changes
that i think we have to seriously
consider and no it does not have to be
barbed wire
and of course this is a public building
and you want the school groups
and you want the veterans and you want
people to be able to visit here
but that doesn't mean that we don't make
some smart security changes to this
building
the use of the national guard we know
after 9 11
the national guard helped for quite a
while we also
know uh that we have to have a plan
going forward as well as consider what
happens when we need a greater number of
national guard in a crisis
and how those approvals are made those
are just some of my takeaways
i'm sure many others will have more but
i do want to make it clear
that there are some items of agreement
between
most of us on this committee and i don't
think we should let the words
of a few become the story here because i
think this has been a very constructive
hearing
and i want to thank our witnesses for
coming forward as they did and i want to
thank senator peters and we look forward
to more hearings
thank you well thank you chair uh
klobuchar i i have enjoyed this hearing
thank you
for your leadership it's been good and
working with you and your entire team
with the rules administration committee
and i certainly want to thank
ranking member blunt and and portman and
all of the members who came here
together today to work in a bipartisan
way to
ask tough questions and to uh to get
answers i want to thank
captain mendoza for sharing her
experiences
certainly a very powerful way to to
start this hearing
but i truly appreciate each of the
witnesses that were here
today who who came here today willingly
and knew you would be asked tough
questions
and you were willing to do that and
certainly we we appreciate you for uh
for that effort
and while this hearing certainly shed
some new light and offered some new
information on what happened to the
lead-up as well as to the response
to the january 6 attack on our our
capital
it's also raised a number of additional
questions that need to be asked for the
past two years
uh i've i've been working to draw
attention to the rise of domestic
terrorism
and specifically violence driven by
white supremacists
we have only seen the threat of this
violence grow
not just from white supremacists but
also from anti-government groups
and people who have been swept up by
conspiracy theories
uh and just simple outright lies
the events of january 6 and the the
answers that we heard today
only further highlight a grave national
security threat that our current
homeland security
apparatus is clearly not fully equipped
to address
our national security agencies were
overhauled and they were forged in the
aftermath of the september
11th attacks and they're basically built
around
responding to foreign terrorist attacks
and they have been slow to adapt to this
evolving threat of domestic terrorism
that we have seen
in the last few years the homeland
security committee was created to
oversee reforms
to fix the intelligence failures that
led to 9 11.
and now i intend to assure that this
committee oversees efforts to fix the
failures
that led to the january sixth attack
there's no question our federal
counterterrorism resources are not
focused on
effectively addressing the growing and
deadly domestic terror
threat the january 6 attack marked a
once-in-a-lifetime failure and now we
have the duty
to ensure that the federal government is
doing everything in its power to make
sure another attack like this
never happens again we must align our
counterterrorism resources and our
intelligence gathering efforts to ensure
we're focused on this dire threat
the fbi the department of homeland
security and the national
counter-terrorism center
right now are eight months late on a
report to assess the threat
posed by domestic terrorism and we're
going to continue to push them to
complete this report
as soon as possible so that we can take
meaningful action
there's no question in my mind that
there was a failure to take this threat
more seriously despite
widespread social media content and
public record
reporting that indicated violence was
extremely likely
the federal government must start taking
these online threats
seriously to ensure they don't cross
into the real world violence
i also plan to keep the pressure up on
social media companies
to work harder to ensure that their
platforms are not used
as a tool to organize violence
so this investigation uh does not end uh
here today
and i look forward to our next hearing
of where we will continue to seek
answers
to important questions that were raised
today and others that need
to be answered before
we adjourn however i have to do a bit of
quick housekeeping
uh it's my privilege to announce the
members of the subcommittees
of the homeland security and government
affairs committee for the 117th congress
the following senators will serve
on the permanent subcommittee on
investigations
john ossoff will be chair ron johnson
ranking member tom carper maggie hassan
alex padilla rand paul james langford
and rick scott the following senators
will serve on the emerging threats and
spending oversight subcommittee
maggie hassan rand paul maggie hassan
will be chair
rand paul will be ranking member kirsten
cinema
jackie rosen john ossoff mitt romney
rick scott josh hawley and the following
senators will serve on the government
operations and border management
subcommittee
will be chaired by kirsten cinema james
lankford will be ranking member
tom carper alex padilla john ossoff
ron johnson mitt romney and joss hawley
so congratulations to our new chairs our
ranking members and to
all members of our committee i look
forward to working with all of you in
the months
and years ahead officially uh the record
for this hearing will remain open
uh for until 5 pm on
march 9 2021 for the submission of
statements and questions uh
for the record with that this hearing is
officially adjourned
very much
foreign